[Musique]
Philippe Corcuch, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Serview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
Euh je suis maître de conférence de
sciences politiques à l'Institut
d'études politiques de Lyon.
Je fais à la fois de la sociologie et de
la philosophie politique. Je suis
militant depuis une quarantaine
d'années. J'ai commencé au lycée, j'ai
commencé au Parti socialiste et
aujourd'hui je suis membre de la
Fédération anarchiste. Entre-temps, j'ai
toujours évolué à gauche puisque après
le PS, j'ai été chez les Vers, après à
la Ligue Communiste révolutionnaire, au
NPA et aujourd'hui à la Fédération
anarchiste. Donc j'ai fait un peu le
chemin inverse euh de la plupart des
gens de ma génération ou de la
génération d'avant.
Parce que votre génération commençait à
Nard et finissait au Parti socialiste,
c'est ça ?
Ou à droite ou à l'extrême droite, même
maintenant. Avant, il y a quelques
années, ça allait jusqu'au Parti
socialiste, mais maintenant il les
barrières se sont se sont transformées,
ça va plus loin.
Et on sort d'une d'un premier tour de
d'élection où il y a eu 66 %
d'abstention.
Est-ce que
qu'est-ce que ça dit pour vous ? 66 % de
d'abstention.
Qu'est-ce que ça dit pour vous qu'on ait
prévu avant les élections un Front
National au plafond et que là on se rend
compte entre les entre les deux tours
que ils étaient soit surévalués entre 5
et 12 % ? Est-ce que c'est une façon de
d'agiter avant le premier tour le
démonte de l'extrême droite pour
les enterrer tout de suite ? Et on se
rend compte qu'après le premier tour,
ils sont surévalués.
Le d'abord le le niveau d'abstention est
quand même énorme he c'est le plus grand
de l'histoire de la 5e République.
Je me rappelle que quand j'étais
étudiant, on se moquait des Américains à
la fin des années 70 au début des années
80 parce que ils avaient que autour de
50 % de participation. Donc on voit bien
aujourd'hui le niveau. Donc ça dit des
choses sur ce que moi j'appelle pas des
des démocraties ni d'ailleurs des
démocraties représentatives. J'appelle
ça des régimes représentatifs à
idéo-démocratiques.
Et donc ces régimes représentatifs à
idéodémocratiques, ils ont des
avantages. Il y a des états de droit.
Les idéos démocratiques ont réussi à à
permettre l'inscription de d'un certain
nombre de droits individuel et collectif
dans les dans le droit. Donc c'est pas
des dictatures, c'est pas des régimes
autoritaires et cetera, mais c'est pas
des démocraties au sens
d'un d'un autogouvernement du peuple par
lui-même.
Et donc
là, ces régimes représentatifs à
idébémocratique, il fonctionnent
beaucoup parce qu'il y a une forme de
délégation qui s'effectue des de la part
des citoyens qui crée une sorte de
légitimité à ces régimes et cette
légitimité est en train de se retirer
avec la l'indifférence qui se crée.
Je crois moins il y a les commentateurs
insistent beaucoup sur la défiance. Il y
a sans doute des zones de défiance, mais
c'est plus de l'indifférence.
Et donc c'est dangereux parce que c'est
c'est pas dangereux parce que ces
régimes sont mis en cause. Heureusement
qu'ils sont mis en cause d'une certaine
façon, mais ils sont pas mis en cause
pour la démocratie. L'indifférence, ça
va pas créer, disons une alternative à
la démocratie. L'indifférence, ça va
laisser l'oligarchie en place.
C'est quoi l'oligarchie ? Ben, ce sont
c'est en tout cas les l'oligarchie
politique, c'est-à-dire les
professionnels de la politique qui
monopolisent les pouvoirs, hein.
Pour moi, il y a pas fusion des
oligarchies. L'oligarchie économique est
différente. Euh euh l'oligarchie
culturelle est différente. Donc, il y a
toujours des oligarchies dans une
société et l'oligarchie politique
professionnelle,
elle va continuer d'une certaine façon.
Donc et cette indifférence, elle ne se
crée pas massivement par des
alternatives à d'autres formes
démocratiques.
Donc
je je crains plutôt
un le maintien de cette oligarchie
politique et de ce que j'essaie de
d'indiquer dans dans mon livre la la
grande confusion.
ça va pas stopper, ça va peut-être même
stimuler le déplacement de cette
oligarchie vers des thèmes d'extrême
droite
puisque d'une certaine façon cette
extrême droitisation de la vie
politique, elle est surtout le fait de
des professionnels de la politique, des
médias et de ce qui se passe sur les
espaces publics, internet, les réseaux
sociaux et cetera.
Je pense pas qu'il y a une extrême
droitisation de la population. de la
société, c'est différent. Il y a un
écart qui se crée entre une société
beaucoup plus composite, mouvante en
fonction des moments et cetera et puis
un espace médiatique et politique qui
s'extrême droitise.
Or, avec l'indifférence qui crée du côté
de du vote, d'une certaine façon,
cet entreoit des professionnels de la
politique dans l'extrême droitisation va
continuer. Donc, je crains que ça
n'arrête pas le mouvement, hein. Quant à
au problème de l'extrême droite, je
crois pas comme je ne crois pas au du
tout au aux théories du complot, je ne
pense pas que c'était fait
intentionnellement. Il y a un vrai
danger d'extrême droite. Simplement
euh il y a un problème avec les sondages
en général qu'avait bien mis en évidence
Pierre Bourdieu, c'est de la crédibilité
des sondages. Et cette crédibilité des
sondages a particulièrement mis en avant
par le fait que il y a une incertitude
sur le nombre de votants. Alors en
fonction de la participation, on peut
avoir des forces politiques qui sont
fortes ou faibles. Là, on nous dit que
les républicains sont forts
avec moins de 40 % d'électeurs, hein.
Donc quand on nous dit que c'est les
sortants qui ont une prime mais avec
très peu de votant en fait. Bon et il
semble que par contre c'est était
défavorable par rapport à ses attentes
au rassemblement national disons
l'abstention parce qu'elle a touché des
secteurs dans les secteurs populaires et
chez les jeunes qui auraient pu voter
pour le Rassemblement national. Non.
Euh donc l'extrême droitisation, elle
continue. Le pouvoir de l'extrême
droite, c'est autre chose, hein. Il peut
y avoir peu à peu une extrême
droitisation idéologique. C'est-à-dire
que les agendas politiques sont de plus
en plus sur des thèmes identitaristes
qui vont concerner la sécurité,
les migrants, l'islam et cetera,
mais par des forces de droite ou de
gauche ou de centre et cetera, sans
nécessairement que ça soit l'extrême
droite qui soit au pouvoir. Donc cette
extrême droitisation, elle passe pas
nécessairement par le fait que l'extrême
droite arrive au pouvoir, mais l'extrême
droite peut arriver au pouvoir comme aux
États-Unis, comme au Brésil et cetera.
Et en France effectivement cette cette
possibilité
est moins impossible hein. En 2002, en
en 2017, il y avait très peu de
possibilités
et maintenant cette possibilité s'est
accrue, hein.
Mais
vu on a vu au régional que quand même
ils ont pris une petite veste.
Ils ont ils ont
Est-ce qu'ils ont pris une veste ? Ils
ont fait moins que aux dernières
élections régionales mais sur un corps
électoral très restreint. Donc c'est
c'est plus la même problème. C'est c'est
si on raisonne en pourcentage ou en
nombre de votes et cetera, c'est très
difficile à à à à jauger. Est-ce que
c'est
une veste ? En tout cas, ils ont pas
réussi à mobiliser
les indifférents, voilà,
qui pour qui pourrait être sympathisante
de leur de leur thèse.
Mais il faut il faut pas aller trop vite
sur l'idée de qui a gagné ou qui a perdu
sur moins de 40 % de votant, ça devient
extrêmement euh compliqué.
Comment vous expliquez ce que vous
appelez l'extrême droitisation des
médias ? On voit on voit qu'il y a
Bolloré
Catau Breton qui fait grossir son
empire. On voit on voit beaucoup de
médias de tendance de gauche. Comment
vous expliquez cette perception de
l'extrême droitation des médias ? Ce que
vous appelez des médias. Alors, c'est
les chaînes d'information, les chaînes
culture, les chaînes du service public,
les chaînes de la TNT, les chaînes
internet. C'est quoi
pour moi ? c'est les espaces publics en
général et c'est pas les médias qui s
extrêmement droitisent,
c'est du clientélisme,
c'est les thèmes.
Par exemple, à la sortie de mon livre,
j'ai accepté
de d'aller dans une émission de Sud
Radio.
Cette cette radio est souvent considérée
comme d'extrême droite ou ayant un
public d'extrême droite.
En discutant avec les journalistes,
c'est pas des journalistes d'extrême
droite. Et pourtant, ne serait-ce que
avec l'intervention des auditeurs et
cetera, les thèmes les chroniqueurs,
des thèmes d'extrême droite sont très
présents dans Sud Radio. Mais c'est pas
une extrême droitisation des
journalistes. Les journalistes étaient
même plutôt ceux qui m'ont interrogé,
plutôt hostile à l'extrême droite, hein.
Donc je parlerai pas d'extrême
droitisation des médias, mais je dis que
une série de postures et de thèmes sont
en train d'être aimanté
par l'extrême droite. Alors, il y a il y
a différents canaux qui se sont
rencontrés à un moment donné de manière
aléatoire. C'est c'est là où ça déjoue
les visions conspirationnistes.
C'est que j'essaie de montrer dans le
livre que
en mettant en avant le politiquement
incorrect
plutôt que la critique sociale classique
de la gauche issu de Marx de
l'anarchisme et cetera, les émissions de
Thierry Hardardisson dans les années
2000 ont été un fil qui a alimenté dans
les postures ce que j'appelle extrême
droitisation.
Les dimensions conspirationnistes à
travers
sylvestre dans les guignoles de l'info
ont alimenté
mais sans le vouloir. Et c'est un fil et
ce fil a rencontré d'autres fils qui
n'avaient rien à voir. Moi, j'ai
commencé à militer au Parti socialiste,
donc lycéen dans les années 70 avec
Jean-Pierre Chevenement qui était disons
le leader, un des leaders d'une aile
gauche marxisante du PS qui s'appelait
le CRS.
Mais comme ce ce livre c'est aussi un un
travail sur mes propres impensés et mes
propres déboirs militants et politiques,
il se trouve
comment
c'était quoi vos déboirs ? Et ben, c'est
que le nom de chevainement est un des
noms qui est devenu
un transfert
de d'interférence entre des thèmes de
droite, de gauche et d'extrême droite.
Alors, évidemment, il y avait pas de
raison.
Pourquoi utiliser le mot interférence ?
C'est interférence en opposition à une
pureté idéologique. C'est une
interférence, le mot est choisi à
dessin. C'est quel est quel est le le la
fréquence saine pour vous ?
L'interférence, ça veut dire que des
choses se mettent en rapport et qui
n'étaient pas avant associé
et que ce n'était pas c'est pas
intentionnel,
c'est des mécanismes largement
impersonnels, hein.
C'est un peu nébuleux quand même.
Ah qu'est-ce qui est nébuleux ?
C'est parce que quand quand je vous
entends dire c'est une interférence
parce que il y a des choses qui sont
venues s'amalgamer dessus, s'agglomérer
dessus à un moment donné et ça s'est
stabilisé. C'est-à-dire que quand je
vous je vous entends formuler ça, j'ai
l'impression de voir une blanche colombe
et ensuite qui vole tranquillement puis
elle se prend une pluie de merde sur la
tête et puis elle est obligé de se
poser. C'est ça l'interférence telle que
vous la
Non parce qu'il y a pas de pureté
c'est-à-dire il y a un trajet
particulier il y a les émissions
d'Ardisson, il y a le trajet de
Jean-Pierre chevinement, il y a les
guignoles de l'info,
il y a la nouvelle droite d'Aline Benoît
avec ces thèmes identitaire.
Ça n'a rien à voir au départ.
Et puis à un moment donné ça va se
croiser et ça va faire une sorte de
bricolage qui va être travaillé par
certains et si ça va se croiser, ça va
marcher à un moment donné, c'est que ce
qui était stabilisé antérieurement ne
marche plus et notamment le clivage
gauche-droite et notamment ce qui
définissait la gauche. Et alors, c'est
qui
définissait la gauche ?
Bah, ce qui définissait la gauche euh
disons depuis le 18e siècle, depuis
qu'on parle de gauche avec ce qu'on
appelle les lumière, la révolution
française, la révolution américaine puis
le mouvement ouvrier socialiste,
euh c'est à mon avis un des cœurs
intellectuels, c'est le lien entre
critique sociale et émancipation.
C'est-à-dire que on va critiquer des
injustices, des inégalités, des
dominations
et on va le faire au nom d'un monde
positif qu'on appelle émancipation qui
suppose à la fois disons une
émancipation individuelle et collective.
Bon,
ça c'est un cœur notamment de la gauche
qui s'est détraqué. Alors, il s'est
détraqué pour différentes raisons. Un,
parce que les deux piliers qui euh ont
développé la gauche au 20e siècle, le
pilier communiste et le pilier
social-démocrate, se sont effondrés pour
des raisons différentes. Le pilier
communiste pour le stalinisme
et mais pas que seulement en France he
dans le monde entier et le pilier
social-démocrate parce que il s'est
fondu dans une forme de néolibéralisme,
un peu dans le monde entier aussi. Et
alors les deux formes politiques qui ont
porté gauche et ce lien entre critique
sociale et émancipation sont en bout de
course disons à la fin du 20e siècle et
au début du 21e siècle hein. Ça porte
plus. Et donc il y a dissociation du
lien entre critique sociale et
émancipation.
Il y a de nouveaux bricolages qui vont
remplacer ce clivage gauche-droite,
cette galaxie de repère qui avait été
constituée à partir du 18e siècle. mais
qui a surtout remarché au cours du 20e
siècle
et à travers ces interférences de choses
qui n'avaient rien à voir au départ
hein. C'est c'est tout ce que j'appelle
ces laboratoires que j'analyse dans dans
le livre et qui vont se croiser à un
moment donné. Bon et qui vont créer une
sorte de galaxie de thèm de postures et
de thèmes. Des postures, c'est comme la
critique du politiquement correct qui va
remplacer la critique sociale ou c'est
le complotisme qui va remplacer
la critique des mécanismes par exemple
d'accumulation du capital dans le
marxisme.
Et puis les thèmes, ça va être l'idée
que la nation c'est bien et le monde
c'est mal.
Il faut réhabiliter les frontières.
Les migrants, c'est un danger. L'islam,
c'est un danger.
Renouveau de l'antisémitisme,
hein, avec l'idée que avec un amalgame
entre deux formes d'antisémitisme.
La la diabolisation de l'État d'Israël
qu'on va appeler antisionisme et puis le
retour d'un mythe antisémite qui date de
18h30 en France qui est le mythe
Rothchild qui a bien été analysé par un
un sociologue Pierre Birnb. Mais ça ça
monte depuis 1830 et ça revient sans
arrêt en France MIT Rothchield. Euh on
sait d'ailleurs que euh Rothchild en
tant que non euh en tant que puissance
euh financière et cetera, c'est presque
plus rien dans la mondialisation
aujourd'hui. Mais le mythe est resté, il
a ressurgi au coup à cause de des
fonctions antérieures de Emmanuel Macron
euh au cours de la campagne de 2017 et
il s'est il s'est il s'est redéveloppé
au cours du mouvement des gilets jaunes.
Donc tout ça disons c'est des postures
et des thèmes, une galaxie de posture et
des thèmes qui vont peu à peu
avoir un effet sur la droite, sur la
gauche qui vont créer des amalgames et
cetera.
Euh
les amalgames de la gauche et de la
droite concernant ces c'est lesquels
droite ?
Ah bah par exemple dans mon livre, je
commence par
trois auteurs qui n'ont rien à voir :
Jacques Juliard,
Frédéric Lordon et Mathieu Boccoté.
Jacques Juliard, c'est une figure de la
social-démocratie, un des plus anciens,
hein. Il a été dans les années 70 au
bureau national de la CFDT, il a été au
Parti socialiste. Euh, il a fait le
tournant ce qu'on appelle la deuxième
gauche autour de Michel Rocard et de la
CFDT. Il a fait le tournant social
libéral de 83 avec l'orientation vers
des politiques néolibérales. Il était
dans la fondation Saint-Simon par
exemple et cetera.
Et puis dans les années autour de 2010,
il va passer de l'OPS à Marianne, il va
devenir républicain, il va être obsédé
par les migrants et par les musulmans.
Et il va mettre en avant l'identité
nationale.
Et on va avoir des thèmes proches chez
Frédéric Lordon qui est la figure
principale de l'intellectuel de la
gauche radicale disons depuis une
dizaine d'années
qui n'a rien à voir parce que c'est même
l'opposé d'une certaine façon he puisque
ce qu'ils ont en commun
ils ont rien en commun sauf que
ils vont mettre en avant d'une façon
assez proche la nation
comme l'identité nationale comme
enracinement quelque chose de profond
qui tient les personnes et une
dévalorisation de ce qui est
international et mondial.
Vous en avez discuté avec l'ordon ça ?
Je sais pas si on peut discuter avec
l'ordon. Si on peut discuter avec Lordon
?
Je sais pas. J'ai eu un débat une fois à
à TC il y a une dizaine d'années où
j'étais à la même tribune que Lordon et
j'étais pas tout à fait d'accord et et
manifestement il avait une thèse
à s'exprimer. Il avait un public et des
fans à satisfaire mais je crois pas
qu'il il est favorable à la discussion.
C'est ma seule expérience mais ça m'a
pas donné cette impression qu'on pouvait
discuter.
Et le trè
le trè c'est beaucoup plus jeune c'est
Mathieu Bocôé. C'est un québécois qui
écrit beaucoup qui plaît beaucoup à
valeur actuelle et au Figaro qui
s'exprime beaucoup en France plus
peut-être aujourd'hui qu'au Québec.
Il est pas connu du tout au Québec. Si
il est si si il est connu parce que
c'est c'est un nationaliste
conservateur. Donc il a il
il s'exprime dans le journal de
Montréal. il passe de temps en temps à
la télé. Donc il a si il est quand même
il a une mais peut-être qu'il est il a
plus de d'écho en France encore
et et lui il défend des thèses ultra
conservatrices hein. La défense de la
tradition, il défend Zemmour, il défend
et cetera et sur la nation et le monde
il dit des choses proches. Je commence
le livre là-dessus pour montrer mes
comment des gens qui n'ont rien à voir
comme Juliard Bcoté et et Lordon comment
se croise à un moment donné des choses
proches.
Euh
comment se créent ces interférences qui
fait que finalement euh les repères
qu'on avait de ce que c'était que la
droite, la gauche et cetera euh ne
fonctionne plus. Alors on pourrait les
revoir ces repères. Je suis pas pour
avoir des choses fixes, mais par
exemple, je pense que c'est une très
mauvaise chose. Je dis pas qu'il faut
abandonner la nation, il y a une
dimension nationale. Il y a des des
formes nationales qui vont pas
disparaître avant longtemps, mais on
perdrait beaucoup de ne plus connecter
le niveau national à une ouverture
mondiale et c'est ce qu'on est en train
de perdre mais par exemple avec trois
auteurs qui n'ont rien à voir.
Donc comment on explique cette
droitisation des médias ? C'est de
l'opportunisme, du clientélisme.
C'est parce que les directeurs de
rédaction sentent leur audience baisser.
Donc ils vont sur des sujets un peu plus
putacliqu et euh il ils utilisent la la
l'aspect le plus primitif du cerveau des
gens. Ils organisent des débats beaucoup
plus saignants. Est-ce que ça vient d'où
ça ? Alors ça ça touche pas tous les
secteurs dans les médias au sens où euh
les médias c'est composites un journal,
une rédaction, par exemple euh les
secteurs culturels
euh sont pas touchés comme les secteurs
politiques. C'est les secteurs
politiques qui sont le plus touchés.
Euh et euh si les secteurs politiques
sont plus touchés, c'est pour plusieurs
choses. D'abord parce que ils suivent
l'évolution des professionnels de la
politique. Et celui qui
être inverse.
Oui, ça pourrait être inverse mais ils
suivent pour rendre compte et cetera.
Ils suivent étamment notamment les coûts
que font les professionnels de la
politique, hein. Euh et et celui qui a
commencé à dérégler toutes les choses
dans ce sens-là, c'est Nicolas Sarkozi.
Le sarcozisme a été un grand laboratoire
parce que il va mettre en avant des
thèmes que j'appelle identitaristes
avec toujours ce lien immigration,
insécurité qui était un lien du Front
National depuis le début des années 80.
le la focalisation sur l'islam,
mais il va faire venir des ministres de
gauche dans son gouvernement. Il va même
demander à un ancien dirigeant
socialiste d'être le ministre de
l'identité nationale.
Il va faire la lettre de Guimok, donc un
clin d'œil à la résistance communiste.
qui va mettre du jour dans ses discours
et donc on va avoir ce cette forme
composite qui va dérégler un peu avec le
sarcosisme et qui et les les autres
après vont beaucoup souvent être dans ce
sillage à droite ou à gauche comme Vals
et cetera vont vont suivre cet exemple
et aujourd'hui on peut dire que
Macron c'est la quintessence même de ça
l'évolution de Macron depuis 2008 depuis
décembre 2008 et une forte sarcosisation
très forte. Marcron commence en 2008
comme réponse aux gilets jaunes. Son
premier le premier discours au moment du
mouvement des juget jaunes qui
désoriente un peu le pouvoir. Ce
mouvement,
c'est quelle année ça vous me situez ?
C'est en 2018.
C'est en 2018 le mouvement he on a le
mouvement des gilets jauges au émerge en
octobre. Il y a la première
manifestation début novembre
et puis il fait son discours sur euh
l'annonce du grand débat national. C'est
la première fois où il rebondit parce
queavant il est un peu dans la panada
et il va commencer à associer
immigration euh
laïcité.
Il va ajouter communautarisme, islam
politique, après ça va devenir
séparatisme. Dans le livre, je suis un
peu toute cette évolution. Ça va être
complètement à l'encontre de sa campagne
de 2017 plutôt sur des thèmes
pluriculturels et qui met à distance les
thèmes identitaires.
Et après, il met à fond là-dedans et
puis il fait des il fait des clins d'œil
à Deviliers,
à Bigar, fait des gros clin
à Zemour
et cetera. Bon euh voilà, il emprunte à
une série de conservateurs, une série de
thèmes sécurité culturelle et cetera.
Bon et il est complètement dans la
sarcosisation. Donc il y a d'abord cet
espace politicien
qui croit c'est une croyance qui a
instauré le sarcosisme un qui croit
qu'il y a une droitisation de la société
et donc comme il y a une il y aurait une
droitisation de la société, il faut la
suivre. Donc ça c'est une idée du
sarcosisme hein qu'il y a une
droitisation, il faut la suivre. Bon
c'est une croyance parce que quand on
analyse la société c'est plus
composible. Je l'ai dit tout à l'heure.
Bon donc je ne crois pas cette idée de
droitisation de la société.
Et donc beaucoup vont suivre quand ils
sont dans des difficultés, ils vont
suivre dans ce sens-là hein.
Les médias vont en rendre compte et puis
les médias vont être pris par des
thèmes, des coûts qui surgissent sous
euh la forte dépendance de Twitter et
des chaînes d'information continue de
plus en plus.
Vous êtes sur Twitter ?
Non.
Vous êtes sur Facebook ?
Non. Comment vous faites pour vous
informer de ce qui se passe sur les
réseaux sociaux ?
Pour dans mon livre, je je prends
parfois ces des matériaux hein parce que
ça fait ça participe du débat public et
donc
j'ai un ami qui m'a aidé et qui me quand
il voyait des choses intéressantes qui
me m'envoyait les choses hein pour que
parce qu'il y a des choses des fois
qu'on qu'on voyait pas.
Cet ami il fait quoi ? Il fait quoi dans
la vie cet ami ?
Il est inspecteur du travail.
Est-ce que ça ça n'est pas avoir d'emblé
un prisme de lecture sur ce qui vous
fait remonter ? Non, parce que moi il
essayait de me faire remonter. Je
voulais pas faire une analyse de
Facebook et de Twitter en général. Je
voulais faire remonter des choses de ces
interférences
he que j'appelle confusionniste
par une seule personne qui est
inspecteur du travail. de temps en temps
quand s'il y avait des des choses qui
étaient intéressantes pour moi deux
personnalités c'est ça et mais qui qu'on
ne trouvait pas dans la presse dans leur
discours de presse hein.
Et et donc de temps en temps, c'est pour
ça que il y a quelques éléments sur
Twitter et cetera dans euh mais comme
complément en fait de choses qu'on ne
trouve pas dans les discours parce que
moi je je n'étudie que des discours
publics
et c'est essentiellement des discours
publics d'élite à 90 %.
C'est quoi l'élite ?
L'élite c'est des gens qui ont un accès
privilégié à l'espace public et qui ont
une série ce que Bourdu appelle des
capitaux. C'estàd des capitaux
politiques, ils ont du pouvoir, des
capitaux économiques, ils ont de
l'argent, des capitaux sociaux, ils ont
des réseaux de relation, des capitaux
médiatique, ils ont des accès plus ou
moins au médias et cetera. Donc et alors
il y a des élites qui ont plus c'est ça,
il y a le capital intellectuel et
scolaire aussi. Bon euh
et religieux,
ça peut être religieux.
Et donc
les
110 locuteurs que j'analyse dans le
livre et qui participe à ces
dérèglements idéologiques,
une bonne partie d'entre eux tiennent le
discours
ces salu d'élite qui méprisent le
peuple. L'important
c'est que et j'ai j'ai entendu dire que
mon livre était sans doute un mépris
vis-à-vis du peuple mais le peuple n'est
dans j'ai vu ça sur des
des commentaires sur les sites quand
j'ai fait des des entretiens par exemple
je pense il y a eu des des commentaires
d'extrême droite après le mon passage à
Sud Radio et il y a beaucoup de
commentaires agressifs et
et négatifs de gauche radical quand j'ai
fait un entret entretien sur médiia
part. Bon bon par bon ça un exemple que
vous êtes bombardé à la fois par
l'extrême droite et l'extrême gauche.
Oui. En général la plupart la grande
majorité des commentaires de gauche
radicale de gauche dite républicaine ou
de d'extrême droite sont violemment
hostiles à ce que je dis.
travaillez bien
ça je sais pas je sais pas mais en tout
cas j'ai c'est c'est des gens qui ne
s'aiment pas en général mais ils
convergent disons sur l'idée que je suis
une personne négative surtout
euh donc sur on a pu dire donc j'ai j'ai
pu lire hein que sur sur ces
commentaires
que c'était un mépris du peuple mais
mon
livre n'analyse pas les paroles
populaire. Mon livre analyse à peu près
110 locuteurs qui sont des journalistes,
des hommes politiques professionnels,
des universitaires, des esséistes et
cetera, donc des gens de l'élite. Mais
la particularité de ces élites et c'est
ça qui trouble et qui crée un que
certains se trompent en fait, c'est que
c'est des élites qui disent "Oh, c'est
salot d'élite qui mépris le peuple."
Voilà. Alors et et ça participe de du
confusionnisme actuel, ça évidemment
hein, parce que euh
d'autant plus qu'on sait,
ça c'est les travaux notamment de
Dominique Pasquier sur internet, sur
l'internet en milieu modeste, c'est que
dans les milieux populaires, ouvriers,
employés notamment qui constituent
encore la majorité de la population en
France, on peut utiliser Facebook, on
peut utiliser internet mais on a un
usage principalement circulant.
C'estàdire qu'on fait circuler des
choses qui viennent de proches, d'amis
ou de la famille, par exemple des
montages photos ou des textes, mais on
n'intervient pas sur les forums, on
n'intervient pas dans les commentaires,
sur les sites et cetera et cetera. Ça
c'est essentiellement les couches
moyennes et les couches supérieures qui
font ça, doté d'un certain capital
scolaire.
Euh mais la particularité de tous ces
discours, c'est de parler au nom des
classes populaires à à leur place en
général. Bon hein, donc il faut bien
faire attention pour pas euh
et souvent ils disent la fameuse opinion
publique.
Euh ça c'est les journalistes qui disent
ça là dans dans ces commentaires et
cetera, on dit plutôt c'est le peuple ou
alors les classes populaires. Bon et
donc euh
en général l'idée c'est que je suis un
salot d'élite
qui méprise le peuple hein. Combien vous
gagnez
euh
en ce moment ? En tant que maître de
conférence de sciences politiques, je
suis quasiment hors classe et au dernier
échelon, je dois gagner à peu près euh
3000 € par mois.
Net.
Oui, net. Oui.
Et en droit d'auteur ?
En droit d'auteur ? Quasiment rien parce
que je vends pas énormément de livres.
Vous
az vendu combien de livres alors ?
Depuis quand
le dernier ?
Ah, on sait pas là. On sait pas, on sait
pas encore. Il est sorti en mars. On
sait pas encore.
Il a été édité à combien d'exemplaires ?
Il a été édité à 6000 exemplaires.
Vous avez prévenu votre éditeur que vous
passiez chez nous aujourd'hui ? Parce
qu'en général, la communauté achète
beaucoup beaucoup de livres.
Ah oui oui, bien sûr. Oui, l'éditeur est
au courant que je passe chez vous.
Revenons à notre question sur la
droitisation des médias.
Boloré qui rachète Europain, du moins
qui prend qui met les doigts dans
europin. Ça vous fait peur ? Ça vous
fait pas peur ? C'est c'est révélateur
de quoi ?
Le le
problème, je l'ai dit, c'est que dans le
mouvement d'extrême droitisation
idéologique actuelle dans les espaces
publics, les chaînes d'information
continuent jouent un certain rôle parce
que ils impriment une sorte de rythme,
de polémique, de thème et cetera euh que
les autres t à suivre malgré tout.
Euh et donc euh
il a suivre ça pourquoi ? Parce qu'ils
sont stupides, ils ont pas proposition
politique, ils surfent la vague, ils ont
pas envie de travailler.
C'est c'est très compliqué. Il y a Je
pense que il y a il y a une partie du
milieu journalistique qui a sans doute
un problème avec le
travail. C'est-à-dire qu'il a y a il y a
une fraction disons du milieu
journalistique qui fait un un vrai
travail d'enquête et de reportage et
cetera.
Et puis il y a il y a une il y a une une
partie disons euh notamment ce qu'on
appelle les éditorialistes qui euh vit
sur ses acquis plutôt et et sur
l'interconnaissance. Voilà. Donc il faut
distinguer les journalistes d'enquête.
Il y en a il y en a un peu plus
d'ailleurs que il y a une quinzaine
d'années parce que le le journaliste
d'enquête a retrouvé avec Media Part et
cetera, avec l'UC a retrouvé une
certaine légitimité qui n'existait peu
en France. Donc finalement de ce de ce
point de vue les choses se sont un peu
amélioré en France par rapport à
légitimité ou une certaine noblesse.
Noblesse, oui, et légitimité et
noblesse. Alors que ça s'était c'était
pas c'était pas la référence
en France principale. Bon,
donc il y a ça, mais il y a
il y a le rythme. Voyez, j'ai commencé à
accumuler des matériaux pour ce livre
qui fait 670 pages en 2012
et d'abord en 2014, j'ai sorti un livre
qui était plus un penflé où j'avais
commencé à à utiliser certains thèmes
qui s'appelaient "Les années 30
reviennent et la gauche est dans le
brouillard". Bon
et puis j'ai continué, j'ai approfondi,
je me suis dit qu'un penflet c'était pas
suffisant, c'était pas ça nous permet
pas de voir l'ampleur des choses. Donc
euh donc 2012 et rien que pour écrire le
livre, j'ai mis 3 ans et demi.
Alors le problème de des journalistes
aimmentés par les chaînes d'information
continue, c'est au jour le jour, c'est
comme le disent les journalistes,
qu'est-ce qui fait lactu ? Et alors il y
a une sorte de vous
pas le bon client pour eux
déformation professionnelle qui une
sorte d'attrait. Certains résistent plus
ou moins et cetera en fonction
évidemment des médias ça peut plus ou
moins résister. C'est pas la même chose
dans un quotidien quand un hebdomadaire.
Bien que les hebdomadaires soient soient
soient très marqués et cetera. Bon, donc
il y a il y a il y a cette forme
d'émentation
en fait euh et euh la
c'était pas dans mon livre d'ailleurs
hein, mais ce qui s'est passé avec ces
news, c'est-à-dire avec le fait que
Zemour, Pascal Pro et cetera, que les
discours d'extrême droite sont devenus
très forts, hein, euh dans sur cette
chaîne
et que cette chaîne est finie par
prendre le
le position de leader chaîne de
l'information continue
et que bon il y a Canal Plus, il y a
Europain là ça commence à faire disons
un un bloc assez important
qui aimente en partie le reste et de
plus en plus sur des thèmes qui viennent
de l'extrême droite.
Est-ce que est-ce que c'est pas une
réponse
au bloc de gauche qu'il y avait dans les
médias pendant des décennies ? Est-ce
que c'est pas c'est pas une une réponse
de de de Boloré et d'autres en réponse à
un bloc de gauche assis et faisant
perdurer le rond rond quotidien
dans une mondialisation fluctuante, dans
une situation économique fluctuante et
que ce rondron quotidien des médias de
gauche n'a pas su s'adapter pour faire
perdurer ses valeurs et s'est fait
bouffer par son sa passivité
intellectuelle et toujours sérigeant
détenteur de la pureté idéologique
universelle.
Le Il y a plusieurs choses, je pense.
C'est
un Boloré, rappelons-nous he Boloré, le
yach
Sarkozi, hein, l'entrée en pouvoir de
Sarkozi, c'est avec Boloré. C'estàd que
sans doute que
il y a il y a une dimension sarcosiste
chez Boloré, c'est de sans doute de
croire qu'il y a une droitisation de la
société française. On peutêtre un bout
de Boloré chez SarkoZi ou
voilà et que donc finalement parce qu'il
y a une crise avec Internet des médias
classiques.
Mais elle vient d'où cette crise ? Ah
ben elle vient que il y a une
décrédibilisation que la presse écrite
ne vend moins de moins en moins et que
disons Internet remplace en partie euh
comme source d'information et que toute
la presse s'est touchée. Pendant
longtemps, la presse régionale était peu
touchée, maintenant elle est touchée
aussi. Et donc, il y a une crise liée au
à l'émergence d'Internet comme forme
alternative de source d'information. les
médias classiques ont du mal et euh que
certains se calent sur cette croyance
qu'il y a une droitisation de la
société, que s'il y a une droitisation
de la société, il faut donner de la
droitisation
pour retrouver de la vigueur. Euh ça
peut se comprendre donc de ce côté-là,
la réaction à la gauche est compliqué.
La gauche et les médias. Est-ce que la
gauche dominait les médias ? Les gens
que c'est situé à gauche
qui se définissaient comme de gauche
disons avait des positions dans une
série de médias. D'abord les médias de
gauche mais qui ont perdu de leur
importance. Voyons le journal Libération
hein qui est qui est devenu faible hein
en terme d'audience. Le monde qui
résiste un peu mieux et cetera, mais
quand même voilà.
Et puis si on prend qu'est-ce qu'on
parle ? la presse de gauche euh
les la radio publique.
Ça a jamais été tellement le cas de la
télévision. Très clairement la
télévision était beaucoup plus de gauche
sur l'ORTF avec des grands réalisateurs
disons communistes comme Stellu
Lorenzie, Bluval et cetera. Bon et euh
sous le de Gaulle, la télévision était
beaucoup plus de gauche au sentier
idéologique que elle n'a été de gauche
par la suite. Bon, donc il faut pas
exagérer cette poids de la gauche, hein,
il est très localisé.
Et le problème c'est que
à partir des années 80 avec le tournant
disons néolibéral de la gauche,
une partie de cette gauche qui était
dans les médias était de droite sur le
terrain économique,
c'est dire social libérale comme on dit.
Donc donc est-ce que c'était encore la
gauche hein ? Bon, donc c'est très
compliqué de savoir si c'est une
réaction à la gauche. On dit souvent à
droite, on dit souvent qu'il y a une
hégémonie culturelle de la gauche et
cetera et cetera. Bon, c'est compliqué,
ça dépend où. Si on voit les si on voit
les rubriques culture littéraires des
journaux, sans doute.
Est-ce que vous avez est-ce que vous
avez vu ce graphique où on voit la
proportion de gens de gauche et de gens
de droite invités dans les médias sur
les chaînes de télé ? Non, j'ai pas vu
ça non. Récemment ou
oui, c'est relativement récent.
H
euh le problème c'est que euh
c'est pas très équilibré tout ça.
Les ce qu'on appelle gens de gauche ou
gens de droite. Ah, les les hommes
politiques de droite sont très invités,
hein, à la télé. Bon, et dans les radios
publiques et même de gauche. Bon, ça le
problème c'est qu' c'est c'est que c'est
souvent les mêmes qui sont invités,
hein. Euh et et notamment à la
télévision. Moi ça m'est arrivé
pour un universitaire, on on on peut
être invité sur France Culture, ça a été
mon cas.
On peut être invité plus rarement sur
France Interre, ça a été mon cas aussi
plus rarement,
mais jamais à la télévision.
Bienvenue.
Sauf sauf à l'époque de l'émission de
TDI. C'est lui qui m'a invité peut-être
trois fois. Voilà. Bon mais disons que
euh c'est vraiment pas et une des rares
émissions où je suis passé à la
télévision,
c'était une mission de reportage sur
Eddie Mitchell puisque je suis un
spécialiste des chanchons d'Eddy
Mitchell et que il s'était déplacé à
Sciencepo à Lyon pour filmer à un cours
que je faisais sur Eddie Mitchell. Bon
mais c'est la seule une des rares fois
où je je suis passé à la télévision en
dehors de des trois fois chez ADI. Bon
donc
les gens qu'on appelle de gauche et qui
passent à la télévision,
ils ont souvent le même discours. C'est
ça le problème aussi, c'est qu'il y a
pas une variété. Or
la gauche, elle est très variée. Il y a
il y a des gauches, hein, et il y a des
orientations. Moi, je suis plutôt
aujourd'hui du gauche libertaire. Bon et
et la gauche libertaire n'est pas très
présente à la télévision, elle est très
présente depuis que son représentant
est en train de passer à droite ou à
l'extrême droite Michel Onfray. Bon
alors maintenant elle est présent à la
télévision mais bon c'était la gauche
libertaire avant encore il y a encore il
y a il y a peu de temps Michel Onf
AZ discuté avec Michel Onf un peu
oui parce que j'ai eu des relations
amicales avec lui. On a fondé les
universités populaires dans son sillage.
J'avais des relations amicales. On on
avait même un projet de livre ensemble
sur l'anarchisme.
Euh et euh voilà, j'ai vu son évolution
euh
et on peut dire que maintenant depuis le
lancement de la revue Front Populaire,
c'est devenu un des
principaux euh
théoriciens de ce que j'appelle le
confusionnisme, c'est-à-dire il met dans
la même revue pour créer cet amalgame ou
interférence des gens de gauche, des
gens de droite et des gens d'extrême
droite. Mais le fait de dire ça, est-ce
que c'est pas srigé encore
en en détenteur de ce que c'est de la de
la gauche ? Est-ce que c'est pas jeter
l'an thème sur les gens qui essayent de
réfléchir avec d'autres, d'avancer
ensemble ? Je me fais l'avocat du
diable.
Est-ce que c'est pas votre position ?
Est-ce que c'est pas une position qui
radicalise encore plus quand on entend
espèce de confusionniste parce que nous
nous on a on a plus de 220 vidéos et sur
nos 220 vidéos, il y en a cinq.
qui ne reviennent pas à la à la gauche
ultra dure. Et pour ces cinq invités, on
est traité de confusionniste parce que
on a donné la parole à des gens qui ne
devraient pas selon eux et qui ne
devraient pas s'exprimer.
Est-ce que est-ce que au 21e siècle, on
peut on peut encore avancer comme ça ?
C'est-à-dire construire des murs entre
les pensées, ne pas écouter l'autre,
même si on n'est pas d'accord et voir ce
qu'on peut faire. Est-ce que sérigé
entre puritanisme politique et et et
traiter et insulter l'autre ? Il y a pas
un une frontière qui pourrait être plus
fine ? Il y a différentes choses. Le
problème, c'est
pas c'est pas euh gênant que des gens
comme Michel Onfré
sur des terrains comme euh la nation,
les migrants et cetera
euh développe des réflexions
avec des jantes droites et d'extrêmes
droites.
C'est c'est une position mais cette
position elle peut être critiquée et
elle n'a plus rien à voir avec la gauche
à mon avis. Donc la gauche doit pas
parler, c'est ça ?
Si pense si on pense si elle peut parler
mais si on pense par
cela
on peut discuter. Je dis élaborer des
choses avec c'est différent. Si on
élabore avec, c'est qu'on n'est plus en
train de créer euh des idées de gauche,
c'est qu'on crée un nouveau type d'idée.
Et et donc il faut en discuter en tant
que nouveau type d'idée, hein. Moi, je
l'appelle confusionniste, ça. On peut
l'appeler autrement positivement. Pour
l'instant, ceux qui créent ça n'ont pas
trouvé un label positif, hein, pour euh
créer. Mais c'est plus c'est ça ça être
dans le cadre, disons de la gauche. Bon,
hein. Donc,
les gens ultra conservateurs, les gens
modérés et cetera ont le droit de
s'exprimer.
Ils do ils ont le droit de s'exprimer
sur cette chaîne ou sur d'autres et
cetera.
C'est pas un problème.
On peut débattre avec des gens
différents, très opposés.
Donc, j'ai accepté
de débattre chez TDI sur RT France avec
Eugénie Bassier du Figaro qui est une
des idéologues ultra conservatrices que
je critique dans mon livre. J'ai accepté
pour l'Express de dialoguer avec Mathieu
Boccoté.
Bon, donc on peut accepter. J'ai refusé
de faire un entretien dans la revue
éléma d'Alan Benoît. Pourquoi ? Pour ne
pas de donner de la légitimité
universitaire à cette revue.
Je refuserai, mais ça m'a pas été
proposé, de discuter à l'émission de
Zemour parce que je veux pas que ça soit
un spectacle
hein de grand guignol. Pour moi, la
pensée, le travail intellectuel, c'est
pas un spectacle de grand guignol. Bon
voilà. Donc je mets des limites, hein.
Je mets des limites, mais je discute.
Mais si je discute c'est que j'ai une
certaine idée de ce que c'est que la
gauche, de son héritage. Dans mon livre,
je fais un peu l'histoire de ça et d'où
ça vient, hein. La révolution
américaine, la révolution française, les
lumières, le mouvement ouvrier, le
mouvement socialiste, le mouvement
féministe et cetera qui suit le
mouvement disons anticolonial. Bon, donc
il y a une histoire, il y a une série de
il y a des conflits au sein de ce qu'on
appelle la gauche, des positionnements
différentes, plus autoritaire, plus
libertaire, euh plus réformiste, plus
révolutionnaire et cetera. tout ça mais
il me semble que ce cadre de de ce qu'on
appelle la gauche et qu'on a hérité au
18e siècle et notamment ce lien fort
dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure entre
critique sociale et émancipation,
on critique des dominations des
inégalités au nom d'une émancipation
individuelle et collective. C'est très
important. Bon et donc je pense que ce
noyau doit être défendu
alors qu'il pourrait disparaître. Voilà
mon diagnostic pour d'autres choses
comme les choses que fabrique Michel Onf
dans Front populaire
ça pourrait disparaître.
Donc moi, mon positionnement c'est que
il a le droit d'élaborer ça et cetera et
cetera et moi j'ai le droit de le
critiquer en le resituant dans un cadre
historique et conceptuel. Voilà.
Donc c'est pas le diable. D'ailleurs, je
pense qu'il faut éviter de diaboliser.
Par exemple, je combats le le
Rassemblement national,
mais je ne pense pas que si le
Rassemblement national arrivait au
pouvoir, il y aurait des camps de
concentration. Je pense qu'il y aurait
une dégradation sur le plan autoritaire,
sur le plan xénophobe, sexiste,
homophobe et cetera et que donc ça
serait une mauvaise chose.
Mais je pense pas que ça soit
l'apocalypse. Je pense qu'il vaudrait
mieux l'éviter.
Voilà. Comme il aurait mieux valu éviter
le moment Trump aux États-Unis, comme il
aurait mieux valu éviter le moment
Bolsonaro au Brésil.
C'est pour ça que j'ai toujours dit que
contrairement à tous les dérèglements
actuels, soit
soit les Bégodo qui préfèrent Marine Le
Pen à Macron, soit les Entoven qui
préfèrent Marine Le Pen à Mélenchon.
Moi, si c'est Mélenchon face à Marine Le
Pen, je vote Mélenchon. Si c'est Macron
face à Marine Le Pen, je vote Macron. Et
si c'est Xavier Bertrand face à Marine
Le Pen au 2e tour, je vote Xavier
Bertrand sans aucun problème parce que
je ne suis pas un puriste, je ne suis
pas pour la politique du pire, je suis
pour une société rasgicalement
différente mais en attendant pour le
moindre mal.
Efficace
parce que
si il y a la dégradation d'arriver au
pouvoir de l'extrême droite, qui c'est
qui va en pâtir ? Bah nous.
Donc on nous dit souvent mais voilà vous
allez pas voter pour Macron quand même
ou pour d'autres pour Mélenchon pour
Xavier Bertrand et cetera mais enfin je
le fais aussi pour moi parce que les
choses vont se dégrader pour l'ensemble
de la population hein.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez du vote blanc
?
Je pense que c'est une fausse solution.
C'est-à-dire que
ça ça intervient avec un vrai problème,
c'est que j'ai décrit tout à l'heure les
systèmes existants comme des régimes
représentatifs à idéodémocratique, donc
oligarchiques, mais qui ont des
idéodémocratiques qui sont inscrits en
partie dans le droit et qui font que son
on n'est pas dans des dictatures et
cetera et que donc il vaut mieux vivre
en France que dans d'autres pays qu'en
Russie ou que ailleurs
Mais
mais comment on change pour une société
différente ces ces régimes ? C'est
difficile. Le vote, ça n'a jamais
marché.
Il y a très peu de d'expériences
électorales qui permettent une
transformation radicale des sociétés.
Il y a une expérience intéressante que
j'ai en tête, c'est la seule pour un
libertaire, c'est la seule qui est le
contrexemple par rapport aux visions
anarchistes, c'est le Chili d'Aliend
hein 71.
Ça c'est mal terminé ça, non ?
Arrivé au pouvoir,
il y a une forme électorale, il y a des
transformations modérées, mais il y a un
mouvement populaire qui se constue, il y
a une vraie élaboration, quelque chose
qui se passe dans la population et puis
il y a un coup d'état. Bon, fasciste.
Mais là, il s'est passé quelque chose
avec l'idée que peut-être une forme
électorale peut aboutir
à une transformation sociale. Mais en
général, beaucoup d'expérience qu'on a
fait que une transformation disons
dans le sens de l'émancipation radicale
des sociétés ne passe pas par les
élections. Mais par où ça passe ?
Voilà. Et c'est ça le le le point où on
en est aujourd'hui. C'est-à-dire qu'on a
un
défaut de solution stratégique, ce qu'on
appelle la stratégie dans le mouvement
ouvrier. C'estàdire comment
il y a ceux qui ont appelé les
réformistes qui défendaient les
élections, les parlements. Il y a ceux
qu'on appelait les révolutionnaires, il
défendaient l'insurrection. souvent
lisons dirigé par un parti d'avant-garde
hein, c'est la forme léniniste. Bon,
la forme léniniste, elle a abouti à des
formes autoritaires qui elles-mêmes ont
donné des formes totalites. Bon,
salinienne. Bon, c'est pas terrible non
plus.
Donc, on a un problème stratégique,
c'està dire c'est c'est pas une
insurrection comme ça. En tout cas,
c'est pas on peut pas faire confiance en
plus à une avant-garde qui va nous
guider vers le les lendemains qui
chantent. on peut pas faire confiance
aux élections. Donc il faut trouver sans
doute c'est un des points et c'est pas
ce qu'aborde mon livre hein, mais c'est
un des points à creuser aujourd'hui. Il
faut trouver un d'autres schémas
stratégiques. Comment on transforme une
société si les élections au mieux dans
certaines circonstances c'est un appui
secondaire.
Voilà.
Par rapport à ça, le vote blanc ne nous
dit pas grand-chose. Le le le vote
blanc, c'est encore une croyance que ça
peut passer par le vote mais qui ne
croit plus vraiment.
C'est une sorte de mélancolie radicale
du vote mais qui veut pas assumer
complètement sa rupture avec le vote
mais qui n'a pas d'autres solutions en
même temps à proposer. Donc pour moi, je
je j'en j'en fais pas quelque chose de
de très important. Si on me demande de
signer une pétition pour reconnaître le
vote blanc, je le signerai parce que euh
il vaut mieux reconnaître l'expression
de toutes les sensibilités et donc le
fait que quelqu'un exprime par le vote
blanc quelque chose, il faut que ça soit
reconnu. Donc ça, je suis pas aussi à
ça. Je suis radicalement pluraliste et
libertaire, mais je ne crois pas que
ça puisse résoudre ce qu'on pourrait
appeler ce que mon ami le regretté
philosophe militant révolutionnaire
Daniel Ben Saï appelé une panne
stratégique. On est dans une panne
stratégique.
On est dans une panne stratégique parce
que
les la réalité rattrape la gauche. On
est dans une panne stratégique parce que
les événements on ont mis la gauche sous
pression, le réchauffement climatique,
les mouvements de migrants, les guerres
qui ont accentué les mouvements de
migrants, les famines,
des chemins migratoires qui
déstabilisent les pays dans leur
fondement même. Est-ce que la gauche
face à à un capitalisme devenu de plus
en plus prédateur est en perte de
vitesse aussi, n'a plus des idées, n'a
plus les capacités de réglementer, n'a
plus les capacités de dans cette
mondialisation effrainée d'avoir des des
une stratégie
ensemble pour réguler le la finance.
Est-ce que en fait la gauche n'est pas
devenue asbine ? Ma question, je la fais
volontairement
provoquante. Est-ce que la la gauche,
telle que vous la concevez, est-elle
taillée intellectuellement pour faire
face au défis du 21e siècle ou est-ce
que c'est une gauche qui s'est révélée ?
Vous vous disiez en 1800 combien ? 1853.
Pour l'émergence de la gauche pour vous,
c'est quelle année ? Non, euh c'est
c'est euh c'est en
en en 1789 euh c'est quand on décide euh
c'est à propos de la la question de la
positionnement par rapport au roi
pendant la Révolution française. Il y a
ceux qui vont se mettre à gauche, ceux
qui vont se mettre à droite. Peu à peu
ça va cheminer
mais ça va cheminer doucement et ça
devient en fait le clivage dominant.
Attendez, partez pas, partez pas tout de
suite au
au début du 20e siècle seulement hein.
Ça met tout le 19e siècle pour cheminer
pour devenir le clivage.
Voilà. Donc est-ce que cette gauche
n'est n'est pas n'a pas émergé dans un
dans une fenêtre historique basée sur
une consommation énergétique facile
pouvant donner des libertés facilement
grâce à une consommation énergétique
facile ? Est-ce que maintenant la gauche
se réduit comme pot de chagrin comme les
ressources mondiales se réduisent comme
pot de chagrin ?
la gauche comme le les idéaux de gauche,
c'est le mariage des idéaux
des lumières donc de du refus des
sociétés d'ancien régime de la monarchie
mais aussi c'est l'émergence de
l'individu. L'idée que l'individu existe
et une autonomie et est doté de raison
et qu'il y a des possibilités de
progrès.
avec
le l'émergence du mouvement ouvrier
socialiste qui lui va lutter sur la
question sociale et l'inégalité de
classe. Bon et c'est le croisement de
ces deux qu'a bien incorné à un moment
donné Jean Jorè ce cette filiation
républicaine et cette filiation
socialiste ensemble
qui constitue un des cœurs de la gauche.
historiquement
euh
en tant qu'idéal et dans la population,
ce n'est pas mort et même il y a
beaucoup d'attentes. Moi en
constituant pendant plus d'une dizaine
d'années le réseau des universités
populaires en faisant des conférences et
cetera, je vois des attentes allant dans
ce sens de gens qui se définissent
toujours comme de gauche
qui sont pas membres de parties. Ils
peuvent être membres
peu actifs d'un syndicat, d'une
association et cetera et cetera. C'est
ce que j'appelle la gauche aussi
mélancolique. Elle attend quelque chose.
Elle est déçue en général par ce qui se
propose. Ce qui est en train qui est
moribon, c'est la gauche organisée.
La les organisations politiques de
gauche.
On a disons une gauche
socialiste
qui s'est convertie à un moment donné à
une forme de néolibéralisme donc qui
s'est déconnecté complètement.
Il y a une gauche qui a suivi pendant
longtemps le stalinisme et qui ne s'est
pas relevé de ça, c'est la gauche
communiste, hein.
Euh et euh
dans ce qu'on appelle la gauche
radicale, il y a au moins deux pôles.
Une qui est tentée par un tournant
nationaliste
chez Mélenchon, chez Ruffin et cetera et
cetera. C'est très net. Bon
et euh une autre je pense parce que j'en
ai été membre qui est incarné par le NPA
et des force beaucoup plus marginales
comme ça qui est euh plus tenté par le
slogan hein.
Le simple et court c'est ça.
Voilà.
Donc évidemment dans la gauche
organisée, il y a pas grand-chose à
attendre, c'est ça le problème. Mais le
potentiel de ce qu'on appelle la gauche,
il est encore présent dans la
population. Il est présent dans beaucoup
d'associations locales et cetera. Il est
présent encore dans les syndicats. Ça a
été peu noté par mais dans la presse
régionale est sorti mardi un entretien
du secrétaire général de la CGT Philippe
Martinez dont on personne n'a parlé.
Qu'est-ce qu'il dit Martinez ? Il dit,
je le connais pas indirectement, je dis
ça. Il dit, il y en a marre que la
gauche soit contaminé par les idées
extrême droite et qui y tacle.
Mélenchon, il y en a marre de ces
discussions. Fabien Roussell, attends
Martinez est toujours membre du parti
communiste. Il tacle le le responsable
du parti communiste en disant c'est
discours sur la sécurité, sur sur le
droit d'asile et cetera, ça va pas du
tout. Il tacl les socialistes.
Donc c'est très intéressant la
déclaration de Philippe Martinez. Ils
font tous à peu près ça. Ils font tous à
peu près ça. Ils veulent tous être plus
calif que le calife.
Non, parce que Philippe Martinez, il est
secrétaire de la c'est général de la CGT
et il lance un cri d'alerte sur le fait
que la gauche organisée politique est en
décomposition, qu'elle est incapable de
résister contrairement à ce qu'elle dit
à l'extrême droite puisque d'une
certaine façon elle est gangrainée ou
paralysée déjà par avance.
Mais ce que je veux dire par là, c'est
que si Philippe Martinez le dit en tant
que secrétaire général de la CGT, c'est
que il existe quelque chose de la gauche
dans les syndicats solidaires, dans la
CGT, dans de multiples associations,
dans la Ligue des droits de l'homme et
cetera et cetera. des choses qui
existent, qui sont présentes dans
attaque et cetera et qui ne sont pas
rien. Donc donc ce dont vous parlez,
c'est-à-dire l'incapacité de la gauche
ou la fin de la gauche, c'est la fin des
organisations politiques existantes qui
n'ont pas su, disons rebondir, hein,
percevoir la réalité.
La réalité, ben ça dépend avec leur
lunettes. La gauche dite socialiste,
finalement, elle s'est laissé embringuer
dans des politiques néolibérales. Est-ce
qu'elle a vu la réalité ? Maintenant,
elle dit qu'elle est contre
l'ultralibéralisme, mais finalement, ça
fait depuis 83 que des politiques
similaires sont faites. Bon,
la gauche communiste dit que elle a plus
de rapport et c'est vrai, souvent le cas
avec le stalinisme, mais elle a pas pu
ressormettre de cette insertion et
cetera. Bon donc la réalité, il y a
plusieurs réalités, il y a différentes
réalités. Il y a un problème de de crise
migratoire.
Alors, il y a plusieurs façons de voir
les choses. Soit on dit il faut rétablir
les frontières, il faut mettre des
barrières,
les migrants sont une menace euh et il
faut rétablir la pureté, disons du
territoire national et donc avec ça de
l'identité nationale et cetera. Il y a
une il faut mettre des protections,
c'est le protectionnisme et cetera. Bon,
ils sont beaucoup à dire ça maintenant.
Oui, même à gauche. Je dis jusqu'à
Mélenchon et Ruffin. Rufin était un des
premiers à à réévaluer la question du
protectionnisme he dans un livre qu'il a
sorti il y a une dizaine d'années. Donc
c'est l'un des premiers à avoir agité le
retour de la nation, du protectionnisme
et cetera dans dans la gauche critique.
Donc ils sont beaucoup à dire ça dans la
gauche dite républicaine dans et cetera.
Bon, peut-être il y a d'autres façons,
c'est-à-dire
la crise la crise migratoire
de Oui. de de traiter la crise la la
crise migratoire, hein.
On fait quoi ?
Un, ça dépend où on est
en France.
Non, mais ça dépend où on est. Moi, je
me mets Moi, je consid je ne serai
jamais au pouvoir.
Pourquoi donc d'ailleurs ?
C'est pas ma J'ai été euh quand j'étais
militant socialiste en 1983, j'ai été
élu d'une commune de 25000 habitants
Florac à côté de Bordeaux,
une commune ouvrière et j'étais simple
conseiller municipal euh pendant euh 6
ans
euh en essayant de faire des choses au
niveau local. Mais avec l'expérience que
j'en ai tiré, c'est que
les structures bureaucratiques,
technocratiques et cetera, même à
l'échelle d'une commune, mettent
extrêmement de barrières pour faire des
petites choses, simplement des petites
choses parce qu'on est une échelle d'une
commune et je précise que j'étais simple
conseil municipal, je ne touchais aucune
rémunération. Ça ne n'empêchait pas les
les citoyens de m'engueuler en disant
queon me payait alors que j'ai jamais
été payé parce que simplement j'avais
refusé de faire changer leur enfant
d'école pour parce que c'était la carte
scolaire à l'époque. Donc je me faisais
insulter en disant vous payez pourquoi ?
Bon alors que je faisais ça
bénévolement. Bon
bon c'est une petite commune. Bon j'ai
une expérience j'ai j'ai quelques
expériences de tout ça. Je vise pas à
être ministre et cetera et cetera. Donc
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire ?
Ben qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire face à la
crise migatoire d'abord en tant que
personne de gauche ?
que les gens crèvent en Méditerranée
d'être ouvert disons à la situation de
ceux qui souffrent ceux qui sont le plus
victime d'injustice.
Bon
donc il faut faire du Cédric etou quand
on est de gauche.
On l'a reçu ici d'ailleurs
hein. Donc quand on est de gauche, on
est on a la question de qu'est-ce qu'on
fait si on est au pouvoir ? C'est
toujours une question. Qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire aussi ?
c'est que peut-être que il faut
réactiver quelque chose qui était très
présent à gauche dans l'histoire qui a
été perdue,
c'est que ce qu'on ce que nous disait
l'histoire de la gauche, c'est que
les salariés, les dominés, ceux qui
vivent les injustices sociales,
ils doivent s'unir, créer des
convergences
contre ceux qui bénéficient de leur
misère.
Donc il voudrait mieux que les migrants
et les ouvriers, les employés français
converge
contre
les patrons français, allemands,
américains et cetera.
plutôt que dans la logique qui est celle
de qui est nationaliste que le principal
ennemi c'est l'autre, celui qui est un
peu plus ou un peu moins dans la merde.
Bon, donc ça ça fait partie de la
tradition de gauche ça. Mais qui
réactive ça aujourd'hui dans la
population comme création de solidarité
?
Donc
il y a plein de choses déjà à faire à
gauche
plutôt que de d'alimenter le discours
qui dit que quand on sera au pouvoir,
on va fermer les frontières, on va
mettre des protections et cetera.
Surtout c'est qui dit ça ? Des gens qui
aujourd'hui je pense à Ruffin et
Mélenchon qui sont largement en dessous
des 10 % et dont l'accès au pouvoir est
est quand même assez lointain. Bon,
alors faisons les choses telles qu'on
peut le faire pour améliorer les les
choses, hein. Bon, donc c'est ça. Et
moi, en tant que simple citoyen, je peux
faire ça. C'est ce que j'essaie de
faire. En tant qu'intellectuel, j'essaie
de faire mon métier.
D'autant plus que je suis payé avec
l'argent public. Donc j'ai un devoir de
donner de la réflexion critique parce
que l'État en tant que fonctionnaire me
paye pour faire des recherches pour
réfléchir et donc c'est un privilège de
faire ça. Bon
et donc c'est faire ce livre,
c'est-à-dire de pointer là non c'est pas
comme ça qu'il faut voir.
Je donne un exemple sur nation et
internationale. Je dis quand j'étais
lycéen et étudiant, j'étais dans ce
groupe le CRS qui était une aile gauche
marxisante du PS. Dans les années 70, le
CRS fait un colloque qui s'appelle sur
le compromis géographique. C'est-à-dire
il se pose la question comment on
pourrait aller vers le socialisme en
France.
Il y a deux piliers. L'indépendance
nationale, la nation est présente, c'est
il faut pas cracher sur la nation. Il y
a des choses qu'on va faire si on
prenait le pouvoir au niveau de la
nation. Et ce que disait le CRS, c'est
que au niveau simplement de la nation
française, on peut pas faire tout seul.
Donc il faut créer des coopérations
avec des mouvements sociaux mais aussi
avec des États qui veulent plus ou moins
décrocher de certaines logiques pour
créer des solidarités particulières.
Bon, si on prend tout le discours qu'on
a connu dans la gauche radicale et
cetera, sur l'Europe et cetera,
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait ? On s'est dit
l'Europe ou la nation et de plus en plus
les gens ont dit la nation.
Mais la nation sans ce deuxième pilier,
c'estàdire il y avait plus l'idée mais
on peut pas faire tout seul. Si je ferme
les frontières en disant je protège mes
telle industrie ou telle industrie. Et
si les Italiens et si les Espagnols font
la même chose,
et ben qu'est-ce que je fais ? Je je
ronds pas avec le la concurrence
néolibérale. Je mets simplement en
concurrence les salariés espagnols, les
salariés français, italiens et cetera et
et eux-mêmes peuvent faire la même chose
avec des rétorsions et cetera. Donc un
protectionnisme généralisé, c'est la
poursuite d'une certaine façon de la
concurrence néolibérale.
On peut tout à fait par contre envisager
ponctuellement parce qu'il y a une
transition écologique dans tel secteur à
faire, parce qu'il y a une reconversion,
parce qu'il y a une difficulté
particulière, envisager des protections
momentanées et cetera, c'est possible et
ça pose pas au sorte de problème. Donc
mais il y a tout ça, c'est un champ de
réflexion mais il y a dans tout ça, il y
a pas que la nation, il y a pas que la
protection.
J'ai compté que dans le programme des
insoumis,
hein, l'avenir en commun, 90 % concerne
la nation et il y a à peine 10 % vagues
qui concernent
l'international.
C'est l'état de l'évolution actuelle,
hein.
Quand
Méia Part, politice et la revue regard
lancent un appel sur les migrants il y a
quelques années, il y a des réactions.
Bon, il y avait à l'époque une tension
entre Mélenchon et ce groupe là. Donc
Mélenchon fait quelque chose sur son
blog d'assez critique. On çait pas très
bien où il veut en venir d'ailleurs
parce qu'on arrive pas à saisir quelle
est sa position. On sait qu'il est on
sent qu'il est contre médiapart mais on
on narrive pas à savoir quelle est sa
position sur les migrants très
clairement. Bon dans ce sur ce texte de
blog. Bon
mais plus grave au même moment dans un
texte assez confus sur son blog du monde
diplomatique Frédéric Lordon qu'est-ce
qu'il fait ? Il il part bien en tête
contre ses moralisateurs de gauche
politist médiia part et cetera qui
veulent être gentils avec les migrants.
Mais c'est de la morale ça ça sert à
rien et cetera. Donc une un dénigrement
de la composante éthique de la politique
comme si on pouvait pas faire de
politique sans éthique comme s'il
fallait c'était un moment où il fallait
dénigrer tout ce qui est moral et
éthique. Bon, il faudrait peut-être
redonner un peu d'éthique dans la
politique et un peu de morale parce que
et la politique ce n'est pas que de la
morale et de l'éthique mais dévaluer
l'éthique et la morale simplement non.
Et puis qu'est-ce qu'il fait ? Il il
parle des classes populaires et des
migrants
et il fait au même moment Mac un même un
discours à peu près au même temps. Voilà
ce que j'ai analyse dans mon livre. En
même moment Macron parle devant des des
députés en vas clos. Alors on a des
quelques échos simplement de la
République en marche. Et il distingu
aussi les migrants et les classes
populaires parce que les classes
populaires sont les premières à subir
les migrants comme dit Macron dans ce et
qu'est-ce que fait l'ordon ?
Il il a sorti les migrants des classes
populaires. C'est énorme
hein. C'est énorme les migrants. Ça fait
partie des classes populaires. Il peut y
avoir des problèmes au sein des classes
populaires. Mais l'idée que les classes
populaires, c'est national et dès qu'on
n plus dans le national, on n plus dans
le populaire.
Là, c'est c'est une sorte de révolution
que personne ne voit de ce que c'est que
les idées haut de gauche terrifiante.
On est au cœur de la gauche radicale.
Bon, donc mon travail d'intellectuel
critique malgré les insultes des gens de
gauche radical, d'extrême droite et les
10 républicains qui chassent les
islamogauchistes, tous ces gens-là,
c'est d'essayer de clarifier les débats,
de voir mais là, est-ce que ça déconne
pas, hein ? Qu'est-ce que serait une
attitude de gauche ?
Ça ne veut pas dire qu'on doit pas
emprunter des choses aux autres,
mais pas forcément de la même façon. Il
y a un des grands penseurs de la pensée
critique, Théodora DO, c'est un des
figures de ce qu'on appelle l'école de
Francfort, hein. Et dans un texte qui
s'appelle Minima Moralia de 51,
il dit un truc bizarre que personne n'a
jamais compris.
Il dit il faut rapatrier
toutes les critiques réactionnaires de
la civilisation au service des lumières
progressistes.
Alors c'est un peu on se dit tout le
monde se dit mais c'està-dire il faut en
fait prendre au sérieux les critiques
réactionnaires et conservatrices qui ont
été faites du progrès de la civilisation
et cetera. Il faut les prendre au
sérieux et même les incorporer d'une
certaine façon mais pour les faire
fonctionner au service des lumières
progressistes.
Alors confus ou pas confus de faire ça ?
Et ben non parce que ici on n'est pas
dans un bricolage que personne ne
contrôle. On est dans une hybridation
qui essaie de repenser ce que peut être
le progressisme et la gauche.
Et par exemple, je j'ai une idée
depuis la Révolution française, on a
tendance à penser que l'émancipation,
s'émanciper, c'est se détacher, se
dédtacher de contraintes, de tutelle, de
domination. Et donc l'émancipation a été
pensée surtout comme détachement. les
détachements des contraintes qui rendent
les gens plus autonomes et notamment on
se détache aussi des préjugés qui
étaient ceux de la société d'ancien
régime hein. Bon
et il faut sans doute
intégrer une série de penseurs qui
écologistes. Je pense à à un
anthropologue et sociologue des sciences
comme Bruno Latour
qui dit il faut prendre il faut prendre
au sérieux aussi les attachements. Il
faut aussi nous attacher au monde
naturel aujourd'hui.
Alors alors il faut sans doute pas faire
comme la tour parce que il faut pas que
s'attacher parce qu'il faut construire
une autonomie aussi contre les
dominations.
Il faut peut-être se détacher et
s'attacher,
hein. Ça de ça ça et on est bien dans la
logique de Adorno. C'est-à-dire, il faut
rapatrier
des critiques qui ont été faites à la
civilisation productiviste, capitaliste
et cetera qui était conservatrice,
réactionnaire et cetera.
Mais dans le sens de l'émancipation,
dans le sens des lumières hein, pour
redéfinir les lumières, c'est ce que
j'appelle les lumières tamisées, hein.
C'est pas les lumières aveuglantes,
hein. C'est pas celle qui nous dit il y
a un progrès nécessaire et cetera et
cetera. Bon, donc il faut donc on peut
hybrider et cetera, hein, c'est pas le
problème. On peut aller puiser chez les
adversaires ou c'est chez les autres
ouer leur critique
intégré mais intégré dans le sens pour
redonner une dynamique à des choses
qu'on va considérer des piliers comme
l'émancipation qui sont des piliers de
ce qu'on va appeler la gauche, hein, la
justice sociale et cetera qui doivent
être maintenus mais sans doute
reformulé. Bon,
l'espace confusionniste, que j'appelle
confusion dans le livre, c'est le
développement d'interférence non
contrôlées entre des thèmes et des
postures d'extrême droite, de droite, de
gauche dite républicaine modérée et de
gauche radicale,
un peu dans le brouillard, un peu
bricolé et cetera et qui dans la
situation actuelle bénéficie plutôt à
l'extrême droite, hein. Est-ce que vous
avez pas l'impression que vos travaux
sont détournés par une partie de l'ultra
gauche pour insulter l'extrême droite ou
insulter tout ce qui n'aurait pas la
même rigueur intellectuelle que eux ou
dont dont eux s'érigent ? c'est-à-dire
espèce de confusionniste
pour jeter la natème pour te discréditer
parce que tu as essayer d'hybrider ou
essayer d'entendre les critiques qu'on
pouvait faire à la gauche et ce de ce
fait par amalgame et par culpabilité par
amalgame, tu es de fait complotiste ou
confusionniste parce que tu as essayé
d'écouter l'autre. Est-ce que tes
travaux ne sont pas utilisés pour
stériliser la pensée ou pour euh euh
c'est une certaine de c'est un certain
puritanisme ?
Dans mon livre, il y a trois grandes
notions : ultra consonservatisme,
confusionnisme, identitarisme.
Je me suis rendu compte que
dans différents courants, ça ça va de
l'extrême droite jusqu'au gauche
radicale.
Il y a une tendance à quand on
appréhende une personne
à la saisir à travers une identité
principale
qu'on lui plaque.
Voilà. alors qui peut être religieuse,
nationale ou autre.
Je j'ai pris conscience avec ce livre
des dégâts de l'identitarisme, hein, au
sens-là. C'est pas tout identitme
d'ultra gauche.
Voilà, il y a des identitarismes, c'est
pour ça. Donc en tant que récusant
l'identitarisme, je défends des
identités hybrides et ouvertes. On est
tous composites.
On emprunte des choses qui sont alliées
à notre génération, à notre famille,
à notre classe sociale, à notre sexe, à
la région dans lequelle on a vécu, on a
circulé et cetera. Et ça bouge. Donc on
a une identité hybride, plurielle et
ouverte.
Donc intellectuellement nécessairement
aussi hein, nécessairement. Donc c'est
pour ça que
euh la le travail intellectuel ne doit
pas servir à diaboliser, hein. Bon, dans
mon livre,
je mets en avant des choses qui sont en
train de se passer au niveau des idées
et qui échappent au contrôle des
individus. Je j'emprunte une notion à
Michel Fouau, j'appelle ça formation
discursive. C'est-à-dire, c'est dans un
ensemble de discours qui sont en train
de se mettre en place
indépendamment de ce que veulent un tel
ou un tel, hein. Et donc il y a l'ultra
conservatisme, le confusionnisme,
l'identitarisme avec tous les tron ont
des intersections.
Évidemment, j'analyse des individus, des
discours dans les médias, des livres,
parfois des interventions sur Twitter et
cetera. Bon,
mais pour moi, les auteurs, les
individus sont seconds.
telle personne
intervient de manière confusionniste
euh
sur un point
par exemple, je pense à son livre
Histoire de ta bêtise à François Begodo
quand il dit que dans un débat au moment
de l'élection de
de 2017,
il préfère Zemour à Enentoven, c'est une
drôle d'idée de se poser la question.
Bon, parce que Zemour, il est du côté,
il a une analyse de classe. Alors là, on
rentre un peu dans la confusion, hein.
Donc euh euh et il dit qu'il préfère
finalement
Marine Le Pen à Macron. Bon, là, il y a
un truc confusionniste, mais la plupart
de ce qu'a écrit Begodo
participe à la pensée de l'émancipation.
C'est-à-dire que c'est pas Bégodo,
c'est une intervention de Begodo dans ce
livre-là. Ce livre là particulièrement
parce qu'il y a d'autres choses qui
posent un problème et qui va introduire
des dérèglements.
Mais c'est pas toute la personne Begodo.
La la une grande partie de la personne
Begodo intervient au contraire dans un
sens que je vais considérer comme allant
dans le sens de l'émancipation.
C'est pour ça que moi je découpe des
discours qui sont en train de se
stabiliser et ponctuellement ou de
manière plus répétée, il y a des
personnes qui participent, il participe
à d'autres discours aussi. Donc c'est
pas les personnes qui sont en jeu. Alors
il peut y avoir des usages notamment sur
internet et cetera
de ça comme étiquette qui disons vise à
stigmatiser des personnes.
Ouais. ou de liste de personnes à
abattre.
Voilà. Mais mon problème au contraire,
c'est que c'est les personnes sont
secondes dans mes découpages. C'est pas
le découpage personne qui m'intéresse.
C'est un un ensemble de discours auquels
ponctuellement ou plus ou moins peuvent
participer certaines personnes. Bon,
ça c'est un travers des milieux
militants qu'on trouve quand tu tu dis
ultra gauche. Bon, je sais pas comment,
mais dans le livre, je montre par
exemple que il y a un chapitre pour pour
faire une critique un peu rigoureuse de
ce qu'on appelle conspirationnisme.
Après, je montre notamment la façon dont
le conspirationnisme n'est pas que à
l'extrême droite puisqu'il saisit
beaucoup de locuteurs de gauche. Bon,
voilà. Donc je prends essentiellement
des exemples à gauche pour euh
pour ça
et je montre une figure particulièrement
tordue, c'est les conspirationnistes
anticonspirationnistes.
C'est quoi ça ?
Je prends notamment un exemple chez euh
l'essée Fiaméta Véner quand elle quand
elle a fait euh dans son livre sur
Thierry Messan autour du 11 septembre.
où je prends un une série de discours
qu'on trouve dans les euh discours
antifa aujourd'hui sur les blogs et
cetera.
C'est-à-dire normalement
la critique du conspirationnisme, c'est
la critique du schéma qui voudrait que
le principal de ce qui arrive,
c'est arrive par des manipulations
cachées par des personnes. C'est ça le
conspirationnisme. Le principal, je
distingue les théories du complot et le
conspirationnisme des complots. Il y a
des complots, il y a des manipulations
cachées par des personnes. Il n'y avait
pas d'armes de destruction massière en
IRAC. Il y a eu des mensonges. Il y a
des mensonges dans l'histoire. Si quand
on critique le conspirationnisme, on
critique l'idée que ces manipulations
cachées, c'est le principal qui explique
un événement ou alors que pour un
historien, pour un sociologue et cetera,
il y a toujours plusieurs facteurs qui
expliquent un événement, un processus.
Donc il faut bien faire attention. Je
remets pas en cause qu'il puisse y avoir
des complots, je remets en cause les
théories du complot. Quand on critique
les théories du complot, on remet en
cause l'idée que c'est des manipulations
cachées qui expliquent le principal. Et
sur une série de blogs antifa, qu'est-ce
qu'on trouve ? On est obsédé par les
infiltrations d'extrême droite et
cetera. C'est-à-dire comme si c'était
les manipulation on cachait qui était le
principal. C'est-à-dire on dit qu'on
critique le conspirationnisme mais avec
un schéma conspirationniste, hein. Donc
il faut faire très attention, il faut
être rigoureux de ce point de vue hein.
On peut pas utiliser contre ses
adversaires des schémas qu'on dit
critiquer.
Baser sur de fausses informations.
Après, il peut y avoir de fausses
informations parce que c'est plus ou
moins bien fait. c'est ces éléments sur
les infiltrations. Bon après, mais
sortons là-dessus, des fois ça peut être
bien fait, des fois ça peut être mal
fait, mais déjà dans cette obsession de
l'infiltration,
dans cette obsession de la dénonciation
des personnes, ça va pas parce que c'est
contraire même à la logique de la
critique du conspirationnisme
comme c'est critique à la comme c'est
contraire la logique critique de
l'identitarisme.
Donc évidemment, il peut y avoir des
usages
déréglés de ce que je peux dire. Je sais
pas s'il y a encore des usages de ce que
je peux dire, mais des discours sur de
critique sur le conspirationnisme ou sur
disons le confusionnisme. Mais ça ça
n'enlève pas du tout à mon avis la
pertinence d'une construction disons
cohérente de la question
des dangers aujourd'hui de l'extension
du conspirationnisme comme de
l'extension du confusionnisme. Pourquoi
il y a un danger ? parce que ça a déjà
existé. Je je prends les années 30,
hein. Dans les années 30,
il y a en France qu'on appelle les non
conformistes des années 30. Il y a une
thèse qui a été faite là-dessus qui est
assez intéressante. C'est des gens qui
sont proches au départ de l'Action
française qui est un groupe d'extrême
droite hein
et qui vont hybrider dans des revues et
cetera des des intellectuels, des jeunes
intellectuels des bouts de catholicisme
un peu intégriste,
des bouts de référence positives au
fascisme et des bouts de références
positives au communisme, à l'Union
soviétique.
C'est déjà quelque chose de ce que
j'appelle confusionniste, hein. Bon,
c'est un petit groupe, hein. Il n'a pas
tant d'écho que ça. Il va jouer un rôle
important. Pourquoi ? Parce que ça va
être le laboratoire avec la défaite
militaire de ce qui va se faire dans le
péthénisme.
Mais c'est pas par l'extension de ces
schémas là. Deux même parce qu'à
l'époque, il existe un grand Parti
socialiste, un grand parti communiste,
une CGT, une CGTU. euh des associations,
c'est-à-dire gauche- droite, c'est
solide, il y a d'énormes institutions
qui les portent dans la société,
il y a le cas de la guerre, la perte et
cetera, mais au lendemain de la guerre,
ça revient.
Aujourd'hui, j'ai parlé, il y a
effondrement de la gauche politique
organisée, il y a affaissement du
clivage gauche droite et donc ce
discours confusionnisme s'étend sans
rempart de manière beaucoup plus large.
Il se développe beaucoup plus. C'est
beaucoup plus inquiétant de ce point de
vue que les années 30 he où c'était
contenu. Voilà. Donc il faut prendre la
mesure de l'extension des discours
confusionnistes et des discours
conspirationnistes,
mais il faut essayer d'en faire une
analyse un peu rigoureuse, historique et
et voir qu'est-ce qui est en jeu, hein.
C'est pas parce qu'il y a des méchants,
hein. Euh le problème, c'est des
mécanismes qui sont indépendamment de
nous. un un des gros travails de ce
livre, ça a été de c'est pour ça que
j'ai mis 3 ans et demi à l'écrire, c'est
que j'ai eu du mal à admettre que
j'avais mal perçu l'évolution de
quelqu'un que pour qui j'avais de
l'admiration, Jean-Pierre Chevenement
et et comment ce nom est devenu un des
noms des dérèglements.
Quand je regardais les guignoles de
l'info, j'adorais ça et je voyais ça
plutôt comme un renouveau de la critique
sociale.
J'avais aucun sens critique.
Et c'est après que je me suis rendu
compte qu'il y avait que que là il y
avait un fil qui s'était constitué qui
avait rejoint d'autres fils. Je j'étais
pas particulièrement critique vis-à-vis
des émissions de d'Ardisson.
Euh
j'ai j'ai beaucoup de
j'ai encore beaucoup de sympathie pour
Michel Omfray
avec qui j'ai eu ces relations amicales
et ce travail sur les universités
populaires. Il y a un un philosophe
important dans dans le livre qui joint
un rôle dans ses dérèglements qui est
Jean-Claude Mich. Bah il se trouve que
habitant Nî lui à l'époque habitait
Montpellier. J'ai développé des
relations amicales avec lui. On avait
notamment comme passion commune les
chansons d'Ed Mitchell et les films de
John Ford. Bon
donc c'est pas l'hostilité à l'égard des
personnes. Au contraire, il m'a fallu
j'ai eu beaucoup de mal à à
mettre certaines personnes dans le
livre. Je me suis forcé contre contre
moi-même. Dans une première version du
livre, il y avait pas Michel Onfray
hein, par exemple. Bon, mais il y a eu
Front populaire et cetera et donc je je
ne pouvais pas ne pas voir qu'il se
passait quelque chose, hein. Et donc
c'est voilà, ça a été un travail sur
moi, ça a été une difficulté, ça a été
sur mes propres impensées, sur mes son
sur ma propre imbécilité parce qu'on est
des imbéciles, on ne voit pas les choses
sur le moment. Il faut prendre un peu de
distance et on voit pas à distance
encore les choses et comment les choses
se mettent en place. Et donc, on a du
mal, donc on bricole. Voilà. Et donc
et donc la stigmatisation des personnes,
ça ne rend pas justice au travail
intellectuel. Le travail intellectuel,
c'est un bricolage artisanal
qui essaie de se défaire soi-même de ses
prêpres préignances, préjugés, évidence
pour essayer de construire un petit bout
de connaissance provisoire sur un petit
bout du monde, un petit bout un moment
et plus c'est près de nous, plus c'est
difficile parce que ça nous colle à la
peau.
Je peux vous couper ? Oui.
Combien on consomme de baril de pétrole
par jour ?
Euh, je sais pas. Je veux dire c'est
c'est pas du tout mon domaine de
spécialité. Je sais pas.
Est-ce que vous connaissez le VIX ?
Le VIX ? Non.
Est-ce que vous connaissez le ribor et
le ribor ?
Non.
Qu'est-ce que vous connaissez aux
fondamentaux de soutenabilité d'une
société ?
Aux fondamentaux de Non, je ne connais
pas. Je je l'intuition
que
mais pas une connaissance directe et
précise, j'ai l'intuition
que des choses pourraient basculer,
que l'état du capitalisme aujourd'hui,
évidemment, il y a les dérèglements
sociaux qu'il produit, il a les
dérèglements humains, mais que dans leur
rapport, disons à la nature, au climat
et cetera.
La logique d'accumulation du capital et
du profit
pourrait aboutir même à à
détruire toute société et donc au bout
du compte le capitalisme.
Ce qui nous montre bien et ce qu'avait
vu Marc, c'est que le capitalisme c'est
pas une intention,
c'est un mécanisme impersonnel,
un vecteur,
c'est une dynamique impersonnelle parce
que les capitalistes eux, ils sont
concurrence entre eux, ils ont une une
conscience très partielle, ils sont
souvent opposés entre eux. Il y a
toujours différentes fractions comme dit
Marx de capitalistes, les capitalistes
industriels, les propriétaires terriens,
les fractions financières, ils vont dans
des direction très différentes. Et puis
après entre les fractions nationales et
les fractions mondialistes, euh il y a
des des intérêts qui vont pas dans le
même sens et cetera.
Vous avez déjà discuté avec un grand
patron de banque ?
Un grand patron de banque ? Non, j'ai
peu discuté. Vous vous êtes déjà
retrouvé autour d'un verre de whisky
chargé au 3/4
avec un grand patron de banque
qui dit le nivellement en France est
toujours par le bas. Ça vous est jamais
arrivé de discuter comme ça à bâton
rompu ?
Non, j'ai peu discuté avec
en fait je connais peu de l'intérieur la
bourgeoisie.
Si je vous dis je vous mets autour d'une
table avec le le directeur général de
Goldman Sax.
Hm hm. Je mets une bouteille de whisky
au milieu de la table et je vous dis
vous avez 3 heures pour vous mettre
d'accord.
Moi moi j'aime pas le whisky. Je serai
je serai pour l'arrake. Armaniaque ou
monsieur a du goût.
Euh je sais pas je refuserai pas
l'expérience. J'accepte en général ce
type d'expérience. Mais euh le problème
des sciences sociales, hein, c'est que
euh
les sciences sociales, quand on fait des
enquêtes, moi j'ai fait ma thèse sur le
syndical cheminot, par exemple, et donc
j'ai vécu pendant 4 ans avec un un
syndicat local de chemin
euh
on fait plutôt des enquêtes
sur les les classes populaires et les
classes moyennes. Donc, il y a quelques
sociologues qui font des enquêtes sur
les les classes dominantes, mais il y en
a pas tant que ça, hein. Bon, voilà. Et
donc, moi personnellement, j'ai pas fait
ces enquêtes et
étant aujourd'hui faisant partie de ces
couches moyennes salariées
euh et venant de
vous faites partie de la haute couche
des salariés, 3000 € vous faites partie
de pratiquement des 01 %.
À 0 à 3000 € ? Non, non, non, non. Passe
pas des 01 %. Non, c'est pas possible.
Le salaire moyen en France, c'est
combien ? 1960 € ? 1600 € ? 1000 combien
? 1350
le seller moyen, je sais pas le le
aujourd'hui je sais pas où est le
salaire moyen mais je suis je le le
salaire moyen n'est pas les classes
moyennes hein.
Le salaire moyen,
je parle des couches moyennes. Les
couches moyennes, c'est pas les salaires
moyens. Le salaire moyen, c'est encore
les couches populaires, c'est-à-dire la
majorité de la population, ouvrière,
employé, différentes formes de précaria.
Mais le salaire moyen c'est pas non, je
fais pas je fais partie des
fonctionnaires de de rang A
et dans l'éducation nationale, on n pas
le système des primes et cetera qui fait
que dans d'autres ministères, il y a
beaucoup de primes et cetera. Donc on
n'est pas dans on n'est pas du côté des
on n'est même pas dans le côté des 10 %
hein.
Euh
ni dans la propriété immobilière ni donc
je fais partie des couches disons
des couches moyennes supérieures.
Alors 82 82 % des salariés gagnent moins
que vous.
Si vous êtes à 3000 € il y a 82 % des
salariés qui gagnent moins moins moins
que vous. Oui.
Oui. Oui. Oui. Non mais bien sûr, mais
attends, les salariés c'est une partie
de la popul enfin c'est c'est pas c'est
pas les plus riches que je veux dire.
Dire les plus riches ne sont pas dans
les salariés hein.
C'est ça qu'il faut dire. C'est pas les
revenus du salariat qui qui font les
plus riches hein.
L'actionnariat,
c'est l'actionnariat. C'est la il y a
propriété mobilière et immobilière et
cetera. C'est différent. Mais donc les
salariés c'est déjà c'est pour ça que
quand on on dit moi je suis pour réduire
l'écart des salaires de 1 à 5
aujourd'hui au contraire on dit de 1 à
20 et cetera les plus radicaux bon allez
on de 1 à 5 mais une fois qu'on a réduit
les les salair on n pas réduit les
revenus hein parce que les salaires
c'est c'est pas les plus hauts revenus
bon voilà donc
je suis disons des couches moyennes
salarié supérieur
les fractions supérieures des couches
moyennes
issu des des couches populaires. Je ne
fréquente pas les les gens euh ces gens
là. Enfin, je je ne les connais pas. Je
je les rencontre même pas. Je je
fréquente pas les mêmes lieux euh et
cetera.
Est-ce que c'est pas ça qui nuit en ce
moment à la société ? Est-ce que le fait
que des intellectuels comme vous qui
disent des choses pas trop déconnantes
d'ailleurs
ne se retrouve pas, il y a pas un
melting pot, il y a pas un brassage des
idées ? entre vous et eux. Comment ça se
fait ? Il faut il faut quoi ? Il faut
tous vous attraper, vous mettre dans un
parc, vous mettre cinq menus autour de
la table et vous faire discuter pour
arriver à se mettre d'accord parce que
quand je vous écoute
et quand j'en écoute d'autres
h
il y a il y a vraiment aucun échange.
C'estd que vous vous ne concevez pas
leur réalité et eux ne con ne conçoivent
pas votre réalité.
Bah je sais pas, je sais pas si je
chercherai à fréquenter par en tant que
sociologue, ça m'intriguerait. Donc je
pourrais euh s'il y avait eu l'occasion,
une fois j'ai travaillé sur une euh
sur des patrons, mais des patrons au
niveau euh au niveau local dans une
chambre de commerce, c'est un peu
différent mais c'est ma se moins
10000 balles par mois, quoi.
C'est ma c'est ma seule vision. C'était
à l'époque où je travaillais sur la la
construction disons d'une d'une
plateforme dite multimodale à à
l'aéroport qui s'appelait Satolas avant
à Lyon. Mais
je sais pas si je chercherai à à parler
à ces gens-là. Bon, en tant que
les comprendre.
Ah oui oui, comprendre. Oui,
pour la comprendre, il faut leur parler,
non ? Oui. Oui. Mais pour moi
pour moi le problème principal de des
dominations
de la domination de classe de genre
racial et cetera, le problème des
domination
c'est la relation de domination.
C'est pas le dominant principalement,
c'est la relation.
Et euh je j'ai je pense qu'il y a une
illusion souvent,
c'est que voyant qu'il faut se
débarrasser de la relation de
domination, on pense qu'on peut s'en
débarrasser en se débarrassant du
dominant.
Stratégique pur,
c'est une erreur dans le sens parce que
on est lié à la relation,
on a des bouts de domination dans notre
corps, dans notre tête et cetera. lui
aussi euh
mais lui il voit qu'il va se faire
éliminer donc forcément il se r puis euh
et puis lui il peut être remplacé. Je me
rappelle il y a il y a 20 ans euh autour
des greffes de 95 le dominant principal
qu'on mettait en avant dans les médias
patron c'était Jean-Marie Messier hein
qui était un haut fonctionnaire qui
était qui avait commencé à accumuler des
positions disons euh économiques
importantes. Et puis à un moment donné
ils l'ont viré et puis il y a quelqu'un
d'autre qui l'a remplacé. C'est pas très
important tel ou tel capitaliste, tel ou
tel banquier et cetera. C'est pas Il y a
une focalisation.
Ce qui me m'intéresse, c'est la la façon
dont les rapports de domination, dont
les inégalités,
dont le dérèglement spirituel. Parce que
je pense que voilà, il y a quelque chose
qui a oublié la gauche, la dimension
spirituelle.
Vous croyez en Dieu ?
Non, je suis agnostique. Il y a quelques
années, j'ai écrit un livre qui
s'appelle Pour une spiritualité sans
Dieu.
Donc vous avez pas vous avez pas d'amis
imaginaire ?
Non mais je dialogue avec euh
des gens qui ont des amis imagineurs.
Croy
Je dialogue avec des croyants. Ouais.
Des croyants en terme économique ou des
croyants en terme euh politique
spirituel spirituel dans le
Est-ce qu'il y a une forme de religion
maintenant dans les partis politiques ?
Il y a une religiosité
dans la gauche classique, dans il y a eu
une sorte d'église communiste notamment
et cetera, mais avec l'effondrement de
ces organisations,
ce qui tient à à ces formes organisées
et moins de l'ordre de la religiosité,
hein. Mais ça a existé, il faut s'en
méfier.
Euh c'est pas de la spiritualité
d'ailleurs. La religiosité c'est
des c'est des façons de c'est c'est des
stéréotypes, c'est des préjugés qui
collent
la spiritualité. C'est ouvrir un
questionnement sur le sens de la vie et
les valeurs. Est-ce que ça ça vaut ou
pas ? Est-ce que ça vaut ? Est-ce que ça
a un sens ce que je fais ou pas ? Et la
spiritualité, ça appartient à tout le
monde, aux croyants comme au non
croyants.
Et ça devrait être une matière de la
politique, hein,
parce que comment on peut envisager une
politique qui reste liée à ces idéaux
d'émancipation nées au 18e siècle
si on se pose pas la question du sens et
des valeurs de l'existence ?
C'est ça être anarchiste en 2021.
Être
anarchiste en 2021, je sais pas très
bien ce que c'est. C'est euh
c'est être radical dans le diagnostic,
c'est-à-dire
facile
que il faut se débarrasser du
capitalisme, il faut se débarrasser de
l'étatisme, de l'oligarchie politique.
Ça c'est un élément important. C'est pas
si facile que ça parce que la
plupart abandonne ce pôle.
Mais il faut être pragmatique.
Je défends un anarchisme pragmatique. Un
pragmatique, c'est-à-dire que si c'est
pour dire regardez comme je suis beau,
je suis anarchiste. Ce qui est
malheureusement le cas d'une partie
importante des gens qui se disent
anarchistes aujourd'hui, regardez mon
identité anarchiste, je suis un rebelle
et cetera. Tout ça c'est de la fouise.
Bon
après il v faire la chasse au confus. Un
anarchisme pragmatique c'est quels sont
les effets émancipateurs de mon action
individuelle et collectif sur moi-même
sur les autres et cetera. c'est chercher
des effets émancipateurs. Ça passe pas
nécessairement justement par les
élections, le vote et cetera, mais il
faut il y ait des effets. Si par contre
c'est simplement
de euh
mettre en en avant ma trombine
de rebelle anarchiste pour montrer à mon
voisin que je suis différent de lui,
vraiment ça n'a pas beaucoup d'intérêt.
L'anarchisme historique était
pragmatique, hein. Roudon, Bakounine et
cetera, Louise Michel, c'est des
pragmatiques et ils sont dans l'action,
hein.
Le il y a des formes de dégradation
identitaire de l'anarchisme aujourd'hui
où pour certains c'est une étiquette
simplement. Bon voilà. Alors moi je
pense que au contraire avec
l'effondrement de la gauche classique,
il y aurait une place pour un anarchisme
pragmatique qui se pose la question
"Mais quels effets sur la réalité ?
Émancipateur ? Quels effets
émancipateurs ? Individuels ? parce que
on peut commencer comme ça sur soi déjà
hein et puis euh après dans la proximité
et cetera, plus généraux, plus collectif
parce que évidemment c'est avec une
soucoupe autrement hein euh qu'on voit
les choses. Je suis en train de pour
pour un article qu'on m'a commandé, un
texte qu'on m'a commandé, je suis en
train de revoir l'intégrale de
la série The War qui vous a commandé
quoi
pour un un livre sur les séries ? On me
l'a demandé de faire un texte sur la
politique de The Wer. Bon, c'est ça me
prend pour un livre qui permettra aux
éditions du CNRS.
Alors, je revois toute
tous les toutes les saisons et tous les
épisodes en ce moment, hein. Bon,
j'avais vu à l'époque
et ce que je suis étonnant parce que
j'ai trouvé le fil un peu de ce que je
voudrais dire,
c'est
s'il y a une sorte de grandeur du
réformisme individuel dans la série
et aussi les déboirs collectifs.
C'est-à-dire que c'est pas la critique
gauchiste classique du réformisme. Celui
qui veut améliorer les choses
immédiatement. Ça c'est la critique
gauchiste en disant mais non là tu
essayes de changer quelque chose mais il
faudrait abattre le capitalisme. Tant
qu'on a pas abattu le capitalisme on
peut rien faire. Bon dans ce cas-là on
fait pas grand-chose parce que quand
même il est là depuis un certain temps.
Bon s'il est pas là depuis toujours, il
est là depuis un certain temps.
Donc c'est pas la critique. The War ne
porte pas et Simon ne porte pas une
critique
révolutionnariste ou gauchiste bête de
la for
combien de saisons dans The Wer ?
Il y en a cinq. Et ça et vous êtes payé
combien pour voir les 5 saisons ?
Je suis pas payé. C'est c'est un article
universitaire mais on n'est pas payé en
général dans le monde universitaire
quand on fait des articles. Ça fait
partie du travail. Je veux dire c'est on
est payé en tant que fonctionnaire mais
on n'est pas payé pour faire des
articles.
Euh
le
par contre il y a des tas de gens qui
essayent d'améliorer les choses
dès la première saison. On voit que euh
c'est ces policiers qui se regroupent au
cours de McNulty, ils essayent de de
faire de faire fonctionner différemment
et de
par rapport au dealer et par rapport à
la corruption, les faits sur sur la
mairie de Baltimor et cetera. Bon,
je peux vous couper, il y a une question
internet.
Ils ont rien de mieux à faire que des
séries télé et des chansons d'Ed
Mitchell, les sociologues pour
interrogation. C'est un petit tacle.
Ça c'est une erreur parce que c'est
c'est très révélateur de la société.
C'est révélateur
du mépris des cultures populaires.
D'ailleurs, il y a peu de gens qui font
ça, hein. Je suis le
ça ça m'a beaucoup dévalorisé d'avoir
écrit des un texte universitaire sur les
chansons d' Michel
et comme le fait que les quelques-uns
qui travaillons sur les séries
aujourd'hui
c'est au départ c'est pas très bien vu
parce que c'est considéré comme une
dégradation du métier universitaire
parce que il y a une
un mépris social à l'égard des cultures
ordinaires et dans le discours
gauchiste, c'est autour de l'idée que la
télé, les séries
les chansons et tout ça c'est
l'aliénation du peuple. Donc tous les
gens sont abrutis et donc comme tout ça
c'est l'aliénation pourquoi ça au
contraire moi ce que mon livre est
ponctué de
de deux phrases d'Ed Michel et d'une
phrase d'Alain Souchon
qui qui parcour font parcours dans la
grande confusion. Alain Souchon c'est
dans Foule sentimentale qui est
d'ailleurs une chanson anticapitaliste.
C'est dérision de nous dérisoire.
C'estàd ce que je essaie de montrer par
rapport à mes propres aveuglements et
aux aveuglements de la gauche et des
intellectuels critiques, c'est que
souvent on est dérisoire et que donc on
peut puiser dans une chanson comme
Chouchon ce regard critique sur sa
propre dérision.
La chanson d'Eddy Mitchell, c'est une
chanson de 80, c'est marrant un peu.
Elle est sortie avant la victoire de
Mitteran, je pense. Ça s'appelle Pauvre
Baby Doll. Et à un moment donné, il dit
la ville les a doublé.
Et ce que j'essaie de montrer dans les
processus, c'est que les gens croyaient
faire quelque chose. Par exemple, je
suis sûr que Bruno Gacio croyait faire
de la critique sociale radicale en
faisant les guignoles. Et moi, mon
analyse, c'est que finalement c'est un
des fils du confusionnisme et du
conspirationnisme, donc de l'ultra
conservatisme. La vie les a doublé.
Question question d'internet. Les
Marseillais de W9, c'est pas une
alignation et du peuple. C'est pas de
l'alignation de l'aliénation et du
peuple. Point d'interrogation.
Je ne regarde pas les Marseillais donc
on peut pas s'intéresser à tout. Donc je
mais je j'aurais pas
j'aurais pas j'aurais pas une vision une
projection. Euh il y a une vision
méprisante
du populaire qui voudrait absolument que
la les mises en scène télévisées du
populaire soient des alliés nations.
Alors, il faudrait voir
les des chiens. C'était quoi
les des chiens ? C'était souvent
comme d'ailleurs les bidachons, une
attitude
typique du mépris des intellectuels de
gauche à l'égard du populaire.
comme les bidochons,
il y avait un mépris de classe très net
dedans.
C'est un mépris de classe ou c'est de
l'humour de droite ?
Je sais pas si c'est de l'humour de
droite parce que ça se pensait comme
étant de l'humour de gauche. Mais de
l'humour de gauche, l'humour de gauche,
ça veut pas dire qu'on ne peut pas
critiquer ce qui est populaire, mais
dans ces formes de mépris, il y a une
forme d'essentialisation. Le le
populaire c'est divers,
c'est composite, c'est contradictoire.
Les classes populaires sont composé de
contradictoir. Il y a pas une unité, il
y a pas une essence, il y a pas une
homogénéité, hein.
Et donc
figer
les catégories populaires sur
l'abrutissement en lien avec les médias,
la télévision,
ça a été une façon de gauche depuis
longtemps. C'est depuis, j'ai parlé tout
à l'heure, j'en ai du bien à Dornau,
mais il lui-même a commencé là-dessus.
Guide bord avec la société de spectacle
et cetera, il y a un fil chez les
intellectuels critiques
de se construire une une identité de
gens intelligents dans le mépris du
populaire. Moi je p je dis il faut aller
voir
sur les Marseillais avant de dire
quelque chose j'irai voir
question internet je coupe je suis
désolé
je vais la prendre je vais la lire brute
comme ça est-ce qu'il a pas l'impression
de se excusez-moi l'expression de se
branler avec des concepts qui sont bien
loin des préoccupations des classes
populaires qu'il défend par idéologisme
euh moi je retournerai la question je me
je voudrais dire
qu'est-ce qui qui a conduit un petit
bourgeois qui s'exprime là. Celui qui
vient de s'exprimer.
Oui. Si parce que selon les
statistiques, il y a très peu de chance
que les ouvriers, les employés
s'expriment comme ça sur internet, hein.
On a une vision maintenant assez nette
des travaux sur internet. Donc comment
un petit bourgeois s'est construit comme
porte-parole du peuple sur internet
avec euh à la fois une hostilité
à l'égard du travail intellectuel, donc
un anti-intellectualisme.
Ça fait partie des dérèglements que
j'analyse dire c'est un symptôme ça dans
la formulation et d'où ça vient. C'est
ce que j'appelle moi les soutiers petits
bourgeois du confusionnisme aujourd'hui.
Donc tu as compris Mika ?
La question venit de Mikage Laris,
est-ce qu'il a pas l'impression de se
branler avec des concepts qui n'ont bien
qui sont bien loin des préoccupations
des classes populaires qui le défendent
par idéologisme ? Et on arrive bientôt à
Moi, je défends pas les classes
populaires,
je défends l'émancipation.
Je je suis contre la domination et
l'inégalité. Après je dépend si les
classes si les classes populaires
prenaient hypothétiquement le pouvoir,
votre raisonnement serait toujours
viable, hein.
Non mais les classes populaires qui il y
a des gens qui ont pris le pouvoir au
nom des classes populaires. Ça c'est
arrivé et ça s'est souvent pas très bien
terminé.
Donc moi, je suis pour
l'autogouvernement de soi. Chaque
individu se gouverne lui-même et le
peuple se gouverne lui-même aussi. Il y
a il y a un lien entre les deux.
Mais est-ce que le peuple il peut
vraiment se gouverner ? du 21e siècle où
on est dans une
c'est pas plus difficile que euh quand
cette idée est née au 18e.
Ouais. Mais là on est au 21e.
Oui, mais c'est pas plus difficile. Il y
a des outils, des instruments et cetera
qui fait que c'est pas beaucoup c'est
pas plus difficile que quand on sortait
de la monarchie que et qu' a commencé à
émerger l'idée que le peuple pourrait se
gouverner lui-même.
Est-ce que vous avez trois livres à
conseiller à notre communauté ?
trois livres,
c'est-à-dire euh comme ça sur avec des
pages un peu de papier.
Oui. Non mais des livres récents, des
livres pas récents,
c'est au bar, vous choisissez ce que
vous voulez. trois livres nécessaires ou
trois livres importants pour vous ou
trois livres qui pourraient amener notre
communauté à creuser d'autres sujets, à
réfléchir, à penser contre elle-même ou
des choses comme ça.
Alors le premier livre, je vais dire des
livres qui m'ont marqué sans doute euh
de la certitude. C'est un petit livre du
philosophe qui m'a le plus marqué qui
s'appelle Ludwig Witgenstein.
C'est un philosophe d'origine
autrichienne qui est qui est sans doute
pour moi le philosophe qui a le plus
bousculé l'histoire de la philosophie et
c'est un livre sur les limites de la
certitude et du doute.
Euh et
ça montre que
le travail intellectuel c'est
l'ouverture du questionnement. C'est pas
refermer les choses autour de dogm.
Le deuxième livre, c'est un deuxième
livre qui m'a marqué
plus jeune,
c'est un un roman de Jack London, Martin
Eden.
l'expérience de ce qu'on appelle les
transfuges de classe, c'est-à-dire
comment quelqu'un qui issu comme c'était
le cas de Jack London, mais c'est on
parle son personnage de Martin Eden,
c'est un peu Jack London et issu d'un
milieu populaire
et va disons aller vers les milieux
intellectuels et bourgeois. Et qu'est-ce
que c'est que ce passage et et ce
sentiment d'être mal à l'aise dans tous
les milieux après qui va conduire Martin
Eden à la fin au suicide d'ailleurs ? et
il a fini Martin Eden alors qu'il avait
pas l'intention de se suicider mais
finalement London s'est suicidé à la fin
de sa vie.
Et le troisème livre euh
je cherche
quelque chose qui pourrait euh
être
important.
le livre d'un sociologue puisque je suis
aussi sociologue
qui est marquant et qui montre que
justement
la sociologie ça doit évidemment mettre
en évidence les contraintes, les
difficultés, les problèmes qui pèsent
sur les personnes mais en fait doit
s'ouvrir l'esprit aussi, l'imagination.
Alors, il y a un livre qui s'appelle
l'imagination sociologique qui a un
classique des années 50 de la sociologie
américaine de Charles Whtmills. C'est un
sociologue un peu indépendant, un peu à
côté, qui était pas dans un courant et
cetera, qui a fait pas mal d'études
intéressantes sur sur les élites
notamment. Bon et son livre
l'imagination sociologique,
c'est la la façon dont c'est une
critique la façon dont à son époque déjà
il y a une tentation de bureaucratiser
la pensée et comment la pensée en fait
elle est artisanale
et elle doit stimuler l'imagination.
C'est le modèle de l'artisan hein. C'est
le modèle du bricolage. C'est le molège.
C'est le le modèle que j'ai hérité de
mon grand-père. Mon grand-père était
ouvrier. Euh, je me rappelle
à la fin de sa vie, il habitait Mignac à
côté de Bordeaux. Il avait un petit
atelier dans son appartement où il
bricolait des choses et euh c'était un
tux, c'est il parlait pas beaucoup.
Et c'est et c'est pour ça que je suis
souvent
agacé par tous ces gens qui qui font du
bruit sur internet et cetera au nom des
classes populaires. Il mon grand-père
n'aurait pas aimé t tous ces gens qui
braillent en fait pour pour dire les
classes populaires, leurs préoccupations
et cetera et cetera, toutes ces toutes
ces tous ces lieux communs qui se
veulent critiqu et cetera qui qui ne
réfléchissent plus afin de se répéter.
Donc euh c'était un bricoleur. Voilà. Et
et euh évidemment euh
j'ai fait un autre métier, un métier
intellectuel
mais en fait je pense qu' on peut faire
ce métier avec une éthique artisanale.
Est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ? une bouteille à la
mer, quelque chose d'impérissable qui
restera sur internet,
quelque chose d' Je sais pas s'il y a
quelque chose d'impérissable
qui pourrait rester sur
internet euh pour les nouvelles
générations
euh euh
c'est c'est pas de moi hein. Euh on
trouve ça de auis chez Adorno.
Euh
dans dans un autre livre d'ailleurs
dialectique négative,
il dit il faut aussi penser contre
soi-même
surtout.
Alors, il parce que il faut penser par
soi-même de plus en plus, mais pour
penser par soi-même, il faut aller
contre ses propres adhérences, hein. Et
alors, c'est difficile, je l'ai dit sur
le le livre m'a mis du temps parce que
j'ai rencontré plein de choses, des gens
avec qui j'avaisé des amitiés, des
choses que j'aimais bien et cetera et
j'ai dû me dépatouiller avec ça et ça me
collait, ça me collait à la peau et j'ai
essayé de de me décoller un peu.
Il faut essayer de construire une
autonomie.
propre,
mais ça suppose de d'aller aussi du côté
de de ses préjugés, de ses évidences et
cetera et et que ça c'est ça c'est le
meilleur message d'avenir d'une certaine
façon. C'est comme ça que les lumières
pourraient perdurer, les lumières du 18e
siècle. C'est que si les gens qui
prétendent penser par eux-mêmes pensent
un peu aussi contre eux-mêmes.
Philippe Corcuf, merci.
[Musique]